hello david
what's up buddy if i leave right now
this will be the shortest
one you've ever done ever ever now you
don't have to do this
i know you're worried you're gonna say
some crazy [ __ ] and uh you're going to
torpedo your life now that you're a cult
guru with strawberry blonde hair
it's more uh strawberry blonde well i
did it's a home job it's beautiful
so it's more um my therapist would
always say lean into
discomfort what you don't like and i
hate gingers so i said why don't i just
become one
i'm like your therapist says lean into
discomfort
yeah if there's something that like i'm
in a men's group also
and they said and i told them i said i'm
going to go back on the joe rogan
experience after
four five six years i don't know when
the last time i was here five right
i don't know it's been a while and so
they go lean into the discomfort oh
start with what you at least want to
share
and i go this is me trying to they don't
know you that well
that's [ __ ] terrible advice for you
so i sit there i'm driving over here
and i go okay start with what i at least
want to share i pulled over on uh
van nuys boulevard and i puked really
yeah i puked
wow um i have a
i don't get nervous you know i used to
have my own podcasts i've talked to you
a million times
um and like i just had like a visceral
response and i was like
and i just pulled over on vanity and i
think someone took a picture of me so if
you're out there
and uh i don't get nervous like these
things
like i'm i'm able to just uh almost
disassociate it's like whatever and just
go right
and just go into any situation and i
just
felt you know and i was like oh maybe it
was the breakfast
i had i had a hard-boiled egg and uh
chia pudding that's what i had for
breakfast so that's it that's it
and i pulled over and i was like oh my
god i'm [ __ ] nervous i'm just gonna
puke
puke i look across the street there's a
guy like
and then i get in the car and i'm like
do i really want to share with joe that
i tried on like
four different outfits last night do i
want to share with him that i got caught
yesterday
at i was eating at the there's a place
called johnny pastrami's in west adams
that just opened it's an old restaurant
that just reopened
and i know the the guy that runs it
danny
and he said um you know there's an
outdoor i don't need an outdoor spots
right now
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm so scared i'm gonna be canceled if i
talk to joe you're gonna be fine
and then i run away through this but
then i go i
i've been canceled so many times like i
kind of like it feels good
you haven't been canceled since the age
of real canceling though
the age of real canceling has been since
you were on the podcast last that's when
canceling is
kicked up to a new level because now the
pylons happen
right before there was just canceling
like you'd get in trouble for things
someone would write an article
like oh my god what did david do he's
crazy but now
the pile on the social media and the
effectiveness of the pylon
has been established so now whenever
someone anything happens to someone
all the the the pile on people but but i
like
i like getting canceled like a lot you
enjoy it did you see the michael jordan
documentary i
still haven't seen it all right i'm not
going to ruin it for you but
it's i heard it's awesome it the the
actual filmmaking is kind of amateurish
but the subject matter is so dynamic
that like you're in it
and like the guy's a full-on gambling
addict yeah you know and
and it's 12 episodes it could have
probably been like four
and the story's the same it's just this
guy didn't give me the best seat on the
airplane this this guy
overlooked me in high school it's like
all these slights and he takes it and he
uses it
as fuel and so i sit here and i go i'm
driving to joe rogans right now i'm
scared to be cancelled
and i sit here and i go every [ __ ]
horrible thing that's happened in my
life
physical abuse sexual abuse verbal abuse
spiritual abuse
prison getting my career taken away or
this or
you know anything has always led to
bigger and better
so i'm like kind of like it you know
that's yeah
but that's just because you're a real
person like you're not
you're not full of [ __ ] in any way shape
or form you might be crazy
but but you're a lovable crazy and and
when people know who you actually
are it's like you have these moments
where things are uncomfortable and
you know and you're confronted with
you know bad a bad scene but then you
rise above
thank you i appreciate that what is your
uh threshold with receiving compliments
my threshold yeah what's your comfort
level i haven't seen you in a long time
uh yeah it's been a while i don't know
can i give you can i give you okay five
sure
okay um you
you're you only look better as you get
older oh thank you you have a
beautifully shaped skull
like as an artist as a sculptor like
i painted you yeah i don't like the
painting anymore i think i can do a
better one now it's awesome it's an
awesome painting
i'm like this guy like all artists and
sculptors out there listening
paint this guy's skull it's beautiful um
you're unbelievably uh
curious inspirational
you give me hope you're funny you're
entertaining and you're a leader
just talk to all your guys right now
like you're leading this charge to texas
right now
and uh you're a
perfectly imperfect
unrepeatable miracle of the universe wow
that's heavy
you're great man well that's very sweet
of you i appreciate you
yeah thank you very much man that's very
nice of you yeah i i i love
you know i haven't talked to you in a
long time but i told you i just
i i'm sure a lot of people feel this way
you're just on all the time
you're in on youtube or on a podcast or
on someone else's podcast so i
still i'm like [ __ ] i think about you
you're in my
you're in my head can i give you uh on
air gift
sure um i was while i was trying on all
my outfits last night i
i was like i want to see who joe's
talking to this mic smells like post
below
so i was uh i was painting last night
and i made you a shirt
oh my goodness because you guys got on a
little thing i didn't listen to the
whole episode yet because it's four
hours but
um you were talking about ghosts at the
beach
ghosts on the beach so there's uh ghosts
on the beach right here i made this
well i didn't make the it's it's uh you
see the ghost
you see the ghosts on the front yes it's
[ __ ] awesome
you could wear it you could give it away
i'm gonna wear the [ __ ] out of this
thank you very much yeah that's
so cool you're welcome that's awesome
man
yeah coast of the beach yeah you never
see ghosts
on the beach all ghost stories are
always at night it's true right yeah
that was a good point i felt like i made
a good point that was a great point
because like every i mean if ghosts were
real like if they were really scary
you'd see them in
cool times like at the pool you know
going back in vegas
drinking everybody's having fun [ __ ]
go shows up freaks everybody out never
so um i got all the embarrassing stuff
out of the way i think
oh no so i was at this outdoor
restaurant yes eating at the corner
and not having a full-on panic panic
attack but i have a nice
beautiful wonderful quiet life now i'm
not on the air i don't do podcasts i
don't do interviews i'm not
i'm not like my life is amazing like i
completely changed my life since the
last time i saw you
and i go i i do want to talk to joe but
maybe
you know maybe i'll just talk to you on
the phone or go visit you in texas like
do i need to go on the air
well i gave you that option i was like
you don't have to do this
but right but i'm a sick person but
you're a fun guy
you're fun people enjoy listening to you
so i had this uh sculpture that i made
and it was in my car and i just brought
it out and i sat next to it and i said
i'm just gonna prepare a little bit so i
started preparing for the joe rogan
experience
and i started talking to this sculpture
at the and i'm like looking i'm like you
know it's
three o'clock there was no one eating
there and i got caught
i got caught talking to a scholar i got
caught talking to sculpture i was
talking to this thing i made
and it wasn't a it wasn't a friend but
it was a guy i knew and he's like dave
and he comes over and i'm like oh [ __ ]
dude and he's like
shame red face i'm like oh hey and he's
like are you talking to a thing right
now and i was like oh yeah i'm going on
this thing tomorrow i just wanted to
prepare a little bit i'm a little bit
nervous i got my nerves
i'm because i talked to you what
thursday no i talked to you
a few days ago and we talked for a while
and i'm like
this guy is a professional talker he's a
commentator he's a stand-up
he has this podcast that goes on for
hours and hours thousands of hours
it's an art you're a painter you're a
mma artist
in in in my world i'm also an mma artist
mixed media artist
right that's uh the bisexual of painting
it's like
you use everything everything anything
goes so
i go this guy is so [ __ ] good at it
because i got off the phone with you and
i'm like
he's so good at talking he's so good at
talking he's just it's like
it's like when you practice something so
much that you don't even know how
how good you are at it you know and um
even even even your podcast they they go
on for a few hours which is against
every everyone's like oh kids they have
no
attention span this these days it's like
10 seconds 15 seconds
it's [ __ ] tick tocks or instagram and
here's this guy he's talking to post
malone for four hours
and and making it seem just seamless and
effortless
and that's because you're a master at it
and i go
i'm uh my confidence level
as far as this art form is low i don't
talk to people anymore
i mean i talk to my friends but i don't
talk as storytelling or entertainment
um my memory is shot to [ __ ] i can't i
watch
three seasons of ozark and i can't even
tell you anyone's name
i go there's jason bateman and there's
the kid and the kid with the drone
and i don't know the wife i don't know
anyone's names
i can't recall anything um
and and you have all these scientists
that are brilliant you have comedians
and everyone's like quick-witted and
they're fast and they're
and i go i'm dim-witted i'm like a uh
human soft-serve i'm like you're
comparing yourself to the other
people well i got to let that go right
now well you are who you are the other
people can't do what you do
um that's true yeah your abstract way of
thinking like the way you are as a
person how you you're so
freely yourself that's what allows you
to create such amazing art
like you just you're free some people
can't be themselves they're not good at
it you're really good at being david cho
thank you you're really i'm horrible at
taking compliments by the way so
thank you it's uncomfortable for
everybody i think unless you're a real
creature you did a great right now just
you're [ __ ] awesome hung in there
that was good could i could have done
more
could have given you like we're good
we're good you want to hear something
funny
okay so the reason why i kind of
did that was i wake up every morning
racked with anxiety and nerves and it
starts immediately
you're a piece of [ __ ] you're no good
people don't like you this and that
and then like what did i say when you
showed me my painting from 2018.
i immediately have to self-dep that's
not that good i could do a better one
so i um
i talked to my therapist about it i say
i i don't have a self i
don't have a high self opinion of myself
and
they go well an average human living in
society today
from morning till night will say
thousands
of horrible things about themselves like
thousands like i'm not good enough i'm
fat i'm ugly this and that just
and for you to say just a few nice
things
i'm like one of those some [ __ ]
stuart smally [ __ ] like and i'm good
enough and i'm pretty and they go
see you did it again you just went right
into it like
why can't you say you're a good painter
you know you're a good painter
why can't you say you're and so they go
give me five right now
five what say five [ __ ] things about
yourself that that
and i i i couldn't give him one i
couldn't give him one
and and they're like don't you think
that's has that always been the case
i think so i think it's uh
to go into that kind of self-hatred is i
could sit here and say it's a
korean thing k rage but it's
gay rage they said you know take a stick
of deodorant
go home tonight and write i am enough
on your on your mirror so you see it
every morning
and i go i'm not doing that that's so
stupid that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
the wasting deodorant yeah they go we're
at
you're paying us you're here just do it
all right fine i'll do it i go and i
write i
am i misspell it e-n-u-f-f i am enough
and then i go next week and they go so
how's it going
you know you're brushing your teeth you
look at them enough i can't see it
they're like what kind of deodorant did
you use
you know the clear invisible one no get
the thick white chunky
whatever yeah old spice and and
like like you're a [ __ ] graffiti
artist right
so okay and i and i said
i can do it but i don't believe it
because i can sit here and tell you
the amount of times in my life that i
wasn't enough
like i can sit here and go through many
many stories
of women dumping me for
richer better looking more famous better
this better that i can tell you of
jobs i didn't get so i i'm not enough
and i'm not
you know so and it's this struggle
it's this burning [ __ ] like the
michael jordan [ __ ] like
i got a [ __ ] i'm not i'm not at war
i'm not
you can't [ __ ] cancel me i've already
canceled myself
how are you gonna cancel someone who's
already canceled there's nothing you're
gonna say
there's nothing you're gonna [ __ ] do
that's going to outweigh anything i've
already said to myself
you uh that guy sucks he's ugly he's fat
he's full of [ __ ] that
i've already said that you know so do
you think that fuels your art
do you think there's a benefit
absolutely yeah absolutely
but you know if there's been that
there's been that debate forever
how do you create great art i'm not
talking about good art
but like the transcendent art the art
that like
is you remember it your it'll live on
for generations
and it's like oh it's like the picasso
and and van gogh
and all the comedians that [ __ ] hate
their it's
it wasn't a debate for me when i look at
the art that i enjoy the comedy that i
like the music that i like
you must [ __ ] suffer you must suffer
you have to suffer uh comfort is the
is the killer of creativity that's what
i used to say and
you know and i'm you know i'm saying it
now but like i'd be like in a room like
ranting this
comfort is the killer of create you
gotta [ __ ] it's the killer of
everything man but i'm rich as [ __ ]
yeah i'm very comfortable but you're
you're comfortable financially but
that's how you keep
sharp you keep sharp by not being
comfortable in other ways
so i sit there and i'm going off on this
rant i'm like in a [ __ ] echo chamber
they're like how long you've been
telling the story for
my whole life i've believe it's not a
debate for me right
for do do you know great artists that
are
comfortable and they're happy and
they're like they have loving families
and
there's always something there's always
something right i think you can have a
balance but you have to have
this thing right whatever that thing is
there's got to be some sort of a
struggle and and that was never a debate
for me i go there has to be that
struggle and they go
but what if you take it away like what
if you chose happiness over great art
what if you chose and they go
dave for someone who's rebelled and like
made your own rules and done everything
your own way
it's so weird that you just kind of
accept this they go
can like what you just said can great
transcendent
next level art be created without that
thing without that edge without
with you pursuing joy and peace and love
in your life
and i go you know what
never tried it i never tried it why
haven't you tried it
what'd you just say i don't know
f-e-p-s-h
fear ego pride shame humiliation that's
why you never tried it
all right [ __ ] you and i go you know
what i'll try it
and i'm i'm today i'm the happiest i've
ever been you know
like i i think i might be a little bit
sick because i'm sitting here because
i'm like
why why would i risk how awesome my life
is right now why do you keep saying that
what
why do you think that you're going to
risk you're you're a fun guy to talk to
we're going to have fun
we we're going but you associate public
speaking and podcasts with causing
trouble
because you were so for people don't
know your podcast was
legendary jamie from being so ridiculous
jamie you're moving you guys are moving
to texas right
will there be any vacation or break
between
i associate i i
i guess because i tell myself a story i
know
a lot of podcasters i know a lot of
comedians
and they don't oh okay you know what
[ __ ] that forget i'll i'll
use i statements i had a podcast and
as buck wild podcast son
i would listen to your podcast sometimes
i'll go god damn dave
holy [ __ ] and you saying that right now
i get a hit right now there's a dopamine
chart going on
i'm like joe the great joe rogan is
telling me my show is
buck wild and well it was it's like you
like even the way you describe your own
anxiety and self-hatred it's like you
there's a freedom
to your expression that you would talk
about in the podcast you would say
the most embarrassing humiliating [ __ ]
and you would say it freely and
openly and then discuss why it's
embarrassing and why it's humiliating
and what you did wrong and what was
[ __ ] up about
it and what you were thinking while you
were doing how you knew it was [ __ ] up
it was like riveting man i remember park
i was parked in my car once and you and
us i forget what you guys were talking
about but i was like jesus christ
i have to see how this plays out so i'm
sitting there
i didn't get out of my car for like five
minutes just waiting for this
conversation to play out
wow thank you i mean i don't even know
where you would even listen to it
i i have a strong support system that of
friends and family that care about me
and uh when i went off the rails and
completely lost my mind
they took it off the air which i went
crazy like i don't even
well this was back when it was on there
i'm sure it's like on the dark web
somewhere
oh that's for sure well we were talking
the other day about how you kept
recording it you didn't
you didn't release any of them i never
stopped i know but what i said is what
you should do
is because you were talking about doing
it again and you're like should i do it
again like what the [ __ ]
my life is so good right now should i do
it again guys this is why i'll tell you
what i said over the phone
and i'll say it to you in person you
should do it if you want to
okay and the reason why you should do it
if you want to is because the world
needs more wild people
the world needs more wild people people
are god damn
scared right now david they're scared
there's a bunch of people out there that
are terrified to be free
they're terrified to express themselves
because they're so worried about being
attacked and it's
that self-limiting and self-censoring is
one of the real problems with social
media censorship
it's not just that you're censoring
people for opinions you don't agree with
but it causes other people to
self-censor because they're afraid i
canceled
i went on stern that was live yeah this
is this isn't live
no okay but you used to be live yeah
it's a [ __ ] high wire act
the highway i don't know what they're
like i'm a severe
like codependent like person like when i
go on the joe rogan show
like i feel like an absolute failure
when i leave here if i'm like i didn't
make joe laugh i didn't entertain him
you already made me laugh
right now no but i'm saying so at that
time we're going back
five six seven years i felt
i need to one-up myself every time like
man joe just said
[ __ ] man you went to a crazy place with
assa so i was like
i took my you ever do you have a lot of
i know you
were talking about alex gray but you
have a lot of painters on here um i've
had painters on here
i wouldn't say a lot but they're
horrible speakers they're not they
they live up here yeah so they have a
very hard time verbalizing
like and i and i get there alex is he's
he's one of
my favorites to have on and to talk to
but he's just so
deeply embedded in the spirit world
right he's got like two feet on earth
and the rest of his body is in this
yeah dimension of of spirits he's an
he's an anomaly but
usually artistic types painters artists
they have a very
difficult time speaking which is why
they paint right they're internalizing
everything
and and i i got bored of painting
i in the same way that when i went to go
to the
you know i'm going to kind of do a weird
flex right now but i went to the
picasso museum in spain and they have
the
the all his art displayed by decade
here's his art from 0 to 10 10 to 20.
if you look at the art that he did by
the time he was 15
as an artist that he's bored he knows
how to paint
whatever like all realistic stuff and
then you just see him going i'm bored
with that
let me go cubist let me go blue period
let me and then at the end it just
scribbles
right it's just like [ __ ] i i'm trying
my hardest
to get back to drawing like a kid where
i don't give a [ __ ] you know yeah and
people go i like this stuff
and for me i'm like man
i people oh man that guy just got lucky
everything i come in i come with like a
killer attitude you know
so when i when i did howard stern when i
did your show and i just started i was
like a year and a half
remember i met with jason kaplan the
producer of the stern show and he's like
you know we have a channel here at
sirius and
and i'm like hold on timeout
i've been podcasting for [ __ ] one
year and i'm gonna be on the howard net
like
my head was like exploding i'm like so
they offered you a show
on their channel we were talking about
it oh and i was like getting pumped up
and i was like i [ __ ] knew i was
awesome at talking
i [ __ ] knew this [ __ ] and and i go
but what am i what are we doing
talking about relationships i'm talking
to a porn star i'm talking to this
how do i take it to the next level how
do i like
yeah when i close my eyes and i hear a
podcast i'm going to interview this
interesting person and
can you believe this person and this
[ __ ] and this facts interesting thing
story weird anecdote and i go talking
dog
[ __ ] no enough with the [ __ ] talking
like i'm a [ __ ] artist
i'm a [ __ ] artist like i want to
bring some [ __ ] to this
what does that look like my guest today
is yellow what i'm the color blue
what what are you talking about dave uh
so i'll tell you
then you [ __ ] tell me here in person
whether this [ __ ] should come out or not
i feel like i need to get high
go for it just keep going i go
what is that like for me to meditate
close my eyes
and be the color blue not think about
the color blue but be the exact color
blue
and my guest today is yellow okay you
don't get high right
i don't get high i i thought
i think you'll see why i don't need i
already see it
and then i and then i go oh [ __ ]
i'll get triggered one day and i'll
think of someone who's like uh like my
enemy someone who's coming after me
i'll be like [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] and i'll
read all the comments and [ __ ] and it's
like dave chose a piece of [ __ ] and i'll
go
i'm gonna become my victimizer right now
and the person i'm gonna interview is
myself
as a kidnap victim what
so i gag myself i gag myself
and then i become the person who just
kidnapped me
and i and i start screaming dave you're
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] because you
[ __ ] do this and you steal
and you rip off people and you're
[ __ ] and i go and then it sounds like
[ __ ] and and
and i and i'm not pretending i'm not
pretending okay i'm pretty
i'm i'm so you're locked in i'm locked
in i'm like
my only goal right now is to try to
convince this guy
to let me go like i'm a kidnap victim
right now right
and i go i need to [ __ ] figure out
how to like
hostage negotiate myself out of this and
then and then i play this guy
who's like my only job right now is to
murder you
i want to [ __ ] kill you right now and
i'm
like my friends come in open the podcast
door i'm on the floor in the fetal
position
and they're like let's go to dinner and
i'm like can you guys
you guys want to hear what i just
recorded this should never go out into
the world
this should never go out i go hey i'm
not gay
but what would it be like to just do a
podcast with a huge dick in your mouth
so i go on amazon i order like a butt
plug and i stick it in my mouth and for
then
three hours for three hours you did a
podcast with a butt plug in your mouth
two and a half two and a half the whole
what does it sound like
i'll put you want me to send it to you
sure
and um why wouldn't you just i i wanted
after like the first couple of seconds
like oh yeah this isn't gonna work
hey there's a lot of nuance to butt
plugs and the you know like where it's
going to go
right there's no standard butt plugs i
started getting q-tips it was a huge one
i was getting tmj my jaw was hurting
jesus and so i'm listening to this stuff
and
my friends are like at this point
there's no difference between you and
the homeless guy
on the street that's talking to himself
that's having a fight with his boss that
fired him 20 years ago
and what's and i go um
were you raised religious at all from
the time i was
like five till i was around seven i
kicked it
you ever um you ever um see people
talking tongues
i have never seen that live but i've
seen a lot of videos it looks like it'd
be a good time
so see you're an adult so you're like
this would be a good time as a kid
terrifying terrifying right so you've
seen it so my mom took me to this church
and i mean i'm scarred
you know like is it pentecostal it was
baptist
baptist so i walked into this room and i
was six
six five years old rising
right and i go mom let's get the [ __ ]
out what and
like these people are touched by god
right now they're
talking directly to god and i go oh my
god like and it stayed with me well
you know i start teaching um autistic
children
when i used to live in san jose art you
know i i tried to uh
um help you know give back to the
community and and my friend uh
said can you start teaching this kid
joseph and then i led to a network of
like all these
autistic children that needed art
lessons so i meet this kid steven
and he can't put a sentence together
hi there like oh hey come on let's paint
today
fearless and we go outside on my deck
and we look at the
san jose skyline right photographic
memory
photograph like not to scale like
everything's off proportion looks very
like
i come back okay steven let's paint he
starts drawing buildings
and i'm like [ __ ] and like this like not
looking
just like and like like some kind of
weird
and i go this [ __ ]
guy that can't put a sentence together
is a genius he's a photographic he's
what something in his brain is tapped
into something that i'm not tapped into
and now some words are coming out of his
mouth that sound like that [ __ ]
uh tongues kind of stuff you ever see
that um
jay-z documentary where they say they
show him like he never writes anything
down like it's all in his head yeah i've
heard them and he's like
and he does like a weird mumbling he's
like oh where he's like
doing it but it sounds like it sounds
like that
so i go i need to do a podcast about
that
so i go in the room and i go right now
as someone who's never spoken in tongues
or not hooked into whatever jay-z's
hooked into and whatever
my friend steven i'm gonna talk that one
went on for six hours
six hours of me creating an alien
[ __ ] language trying to talk directly
to god
and that one 100 of my friends go
you cannot put this out so you have a
[ __ ] butt plug in your mouth you're
talking in tongues to god
you're kidnapping yourself and hold up
these aren't all the same episode right
no no the many different
but the butt plug you didn't talk
tongues with the butt plug right this is
that it sounds very similar those two
episodes are very
but the talking tongues so you there was
no real words you just sat down and just
this is what the butt plug one sounds
like
how many hours does it go for a while i
don't understand why you wouldn't have
stopped after the first few seconds
that's a hell of a butt plug like a
water bottle an eight ounce
what is it it's eight ounces sixteen
yeah
well eight ounces of meat
the language thing that you did did you
talk any english you just get in there
and
my goal was podcast just don't don't try
to
i want this to sound like complete
gibberish
right yeah so from the moment you
started there was no like
hello uh i'm gonna try something right
now i don't know
you know who did that man it was real
weird uh mckenna used to do that
terence mckenna used to uh he used to do
it i think he did it under the influence
of psychedelics
he would talk in like these weird uh
crazy
fake words what is that called there's a
there's a term for it not just speaking
in tongues glossolalia
is that oh uh a scat glo it's called
glossolalia
yeah oh is this mckenna yeah play this
just so you can listen to some of this
um seems to be
it's it's language-like activity because
he talks about it
oh he talks about it it's very
interesting well he i've heard him do it
in there was a song he did a thing
with uh you want to try it with me right
now sure what do you want to do
don't don't use any words that sound
like the english language
just close your eyes and try to think i
have to close my eyes just just to like
you don't have to close your eyes
sounds fake see you need time you need
time need time to work on that
but i would bet but does anyone need to
hear that
see i need to get on that level
i [ __ ] dare you to do stand up in uh
that language no people pay money
people pay money i can't do that to them
by myself alone maybe
but that that thing i was just joking
around about it
was it with was it the post malone thing
i was saying i think that aliens
would be so good at language they would
be able to talk to us
in a in a language and we would
understand it
that they would be able to figure out
sound to the point where sound
could trip they could they could embed
information in sound with their super
complicated language
to the point where they could talk to
you and you don't have to understand
their language you don't know by now
well what do i not know you're an alien
oh
that's ridiculous like the mountain you
you don't think there's any part of you
that your fascination with it that
you might be like a sleeper cell that no
i'm serious like
what come on oh i've heard all this like
simulation theory
what are the chances that
this man with this beautifully shaped
skull is born on planet earth
and whatever there's probably some kind
of block that's but then
you you become this person
and you use the human voice to connect
with
sports science um comedy
and then you amass an audience of
hundreds of millions of people and
i go this fucker's an alien no there's
no way you're an alien
no i think you're in it i'm a [ __ ]
listen to me trust me
i just do things a lot that's what i do
i just do things until i get good at
them
i will start the church man i'll [ __ ]
join
joe rogan i don't have any talent at
anything
see you're doing it right now then
working hard
and getting obsessed with things that's
my number one time you're extremely
talented
well i had physical talent when i was
when i was
started doing taekwondo i had physical
advantages that i recognized very early
they're real advantages like
some people just have extra speed they
have extra power they have things
that their body can do that's not it's
not warranted by the amount of effort
they put into it
there's there's that but aft outside of
that everything has just been being
obsessed with things
and that's a human characteristic that's
not an alien characteristic
and uh a lot of it is like we have our
own
struggles right like your struggle is
you tell yourself you're not good
i don't tell myself i'm not good but i'm
never i'm never
fully satisfied with anything like
anything that i do
personally whether it's the way i behave
or the things that i write
or or perform or podcast or a stand-up
comedy special
so you do the same [ __ ] i just did yeah
but i don't hate myself but i'm never
happy
i'm never happy with myself but i'm
never i get to a point where i go
all right let's i did my best i know i
put in the effort
i know so that's researched it so that's
what makes you inhuman
because most humans do hate themselves
well what it is is that alien
[ __ ]
because of the fact that i'm obsessed
with doing
better at things i put the work in and
from my own personal experience when i
have had moments of self-hating it's not
like i just never had any self-hating
it was mostly because i didn't put the
work in you spend a lot of time with
this guy have you ever seen him do like
weird bathroom rich or like anything
that would be like non-human
maybe you're [ __ ] alien too jamie's
way more of an alien than me
he jamie reads my mind 100 wow i'm about
to say something and jamie will just go
and he'll type it up did you know um
chester from
linkin park i did not i met him once but
i did not know him
so i know joe han in his band the dj guy
so um i went to his house once and he
played i don't know what you call
scratch tracks or something and the way
i know that they make music is
they all live in different cities so
they just like the guitar player will
make something and then send it to
like mike shinoda and and joe played me
an entire album where chester just sings
over every track
gibberish oh wow and it sounded better
than any other music
that i've ever heard and it was like
because he's just trying to get the
and it was like scat i don't know what
you call it do you know um the the black
keys
i i've heard their music i don't know
that dan an hour back yeah
he told me he just makes up words that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah he just like he first of all that
guy smokes tons of weed i mean just
constantly high
right he's like i get high and i just uh
i just come up with lyrics i just start
singing i start playing
and i make up words wow like you make up
words he goes yeah yeah yeah so that's
sound yeah [ __ ] yeah it's hard so you
just said something my keys are
phenomenal these people are paying money
to come see me do comedy so i'm not
gonna do
my true alien tongue version stand-up
set
that's something i would have to
practice right see that's that's the
thing like if i'm gonna
that would be too indulgent to do it in
front of them without any practice
if i knew that there was a way that i
could do it that i could distill it down
to an
entertaining form right i would
definitely do it so you've
you've done like thousands of these now
yeah you've had every single
different kind of profession and weird
personality sitting here
and and i was getting to the point in my
podcast where i was getting pretty big
guests
and and i was finding myself
dissatisfied but unlike you hating
myself
and becoming very bored and i said
i'm i'm not good at speaking because i
have blind spots
i stutter i say like a lot i say um i
talk over people
and i'm trying to sort of like wedge my
agenda and try to get my point across
and i go if my consciousness
my soul who's talking in this mic right
now
is what is the interview we want to
learn
about ourselves through another person
we want to learn you know and i go
there's a lot of people living inside me
there's a lot of there's like
i'm like oh there's a guy here right now
that's [ __ ] puking on this on van
nuys boulevard
and there's another guy that's super
confident and cocky and
so i go there you're a collective
there's a short bus in my brain and the
person driving right now
today right now is a confident sober
mentally stable
but on that bus there's a racist dave
there's a sexist dave
there's a werewolf dave there's a trans
dave there's a
uh experimental butt plug dave there's
there's many daves
and there it's whatever attention i
i want to give them yeah and um you ever
done a psychodrama
psychodrama yeah what is that
it's like a therapy tool where
um you're in a room like this with uh
like
five other patients um
and or i don't know it could be like up
to 10 i guess
and you identify
one of the most traumatic moments of
your life
and that you can't you're stuck you get
you can't get past i can't get past
my parents divorcing i can't get past
failing at the
you know national you know whatever that
moment is okay and so then
you keep playing that on a loop in your
brain and no matter what you do in life
that's always still going on
and so it's a tool to to rewire your
brain
so it's like okay you're going to play
yourself how old were you then
16 okay so you're joe rogan 16 who was
there
my dad was there my mom was there my
coach you know and then so all
the other people play the roles of those
things and then you just go through and
then what happened and then this guy
punched me
pause what are you smelling right now
you go around the room
then it you just dissect the moment and
you're like so what did you need at that
moment well i needed my dad to [ __ ]
step up for me
and but did he no so in this version
have him come in so you're rewriting
history and
um i go home
i've done hundreds of these now and i go
has anyone ever done a psychodrama with
themselves
right because there's many voices on the
101
over here it's like dave turn the car
around
who's talking right now scared [ __ ]
confident dave we need you up on the bus
come to the front okay
hey um why the [ __ ] did you stick a
nestle pure life water ball in your
mouth
because you wanted to explain to joe
what a butt plug
did you need to do that and then so i do
this for a few hours
of course i'm recording and once again
i'm in a [ __ ] room talking with a hot
mic
crying laughing screaming
to myself this sounds like an awesome ad
for a patreon page this is what you do
you take those episodes you start new
ones and you take those crazy ones and
you just put it
put it up only for patreon members
and just ask him to please not share it
unless people are paying and then use
that money for charity
probably make a million dollars in a
week
i don't know i i'm i'm trying to
heal myself we all are right we all are
what what you're saying is it mirrored
in a lot of people
especially the you're you're different
i'm different person all the time
i'm a lot of different people and um
some of them have their [ __ ] together
and those ones guide the other ones away
from the
the [ __ ] rocks in a in a fight
flight or free situation what are you
because i'm i'll i'll just tell you i
could give a master class if you can't
get out
you should get out always [ __ ] you can
fly if you
flight is always the best option i'm a
master freezer
you can't freeze flight i'm either
flight or fight
those are one it's one or two and you
can't take either one of them lightly
okay so if you're fl if your flight you
have to know there's a reason to get out
and that reason has to make sense and
you
you have to be able to assess very
quickly whether or not this is even
going to work are you going to get out
of here
is this going to work or am i gonna have
to fight and if i'm gonna have to fight
i should fight now
and i should be only thinking about that
you can't if you're gonna fight you can
never think
maybe i shouldn't be doing this or maybe
i should get out maybe i should back off
maybe i should uh i don't know maybe i
[ __ ] up you can't think that
once you pull the trigger you got to let
the wolf out of the cage
okay and if you're gonna run you gotta
run you gotta you can't
you can't go jesus am i really running
what am i doing no you just gotta
go you gotta get the [ __ ] out of there
you can't worry about your ego
if you can escape especially violent
encounters if you can escape and your
ego's the only thing that gets damaged
congratulations
your ego can you can get over that but
physical violence is terrifying so i
need your help then
okay okay i told you the other day
um this this is pre-quarantine
pre-panda i'm in the car with my dad
and we were going to our favorite
chinese restaurant in san gabriel valley
which by where we live should take 15 20
minutes tops
we live in los angeles i look at the
google maps says an hour and ten minutes
to get there
primally traffic my dad had a stroke two
years ago so he's
got a kind of gimpy leg he sort of drags
his foot so i'm like his
uh uber driver now i take him everywhere
and um
and he's he's like a typical old korean
guy he doesn't
he likes to eat close to home no lines
fast
in and out done so yeah we get in the
car
5 30 6 at on a weekday night and it's
just
traffic bumper to bumper and uh he's
like [ __ ] look at this traffic
and the thing that added to this which i
didn't know was it was the academy
awards night
oh no so now it's like we're not moving
and we're sitting we're sitting at the
light and my phone starts blowing up
like congratulations like [ __ ] like all
caps
you know what what's going on i look at
my phone my dad's like hey
don't look at your phone when you're
driving like we're not going anywhere
bro chill the [ __ ] out
and parasite the korean film had just
won
best film like in the american academy
awards
and all my non-white friends are
starting to like because asians all know
each other right
we kind of do but congratulations on
parasite and i go i had nothing to do
with that movie
well you get waiting you're getting
congratulated because it's korean
yeah they're like you must be so proud
of your people like you you did it man
let me ask you this is that racist
for them to do that it seems a little
racist
it's a racist congratulatory thing like
people
like if somebody called me up and
congratulated me for something italians
did i'd be like what
beautiful [ __ ] is wrong with you
beautiful meatball
i don't even know that guy so that's
what i'm saying i'm in the car going i
don't even [ __ ] know that guy
is it all white people that are calling
you congratulations one one mexican guy
two two white guys it's three people
three people and it's
the news just hit okay first time in
history non-american
film wins you know it's a big deal the
koreans are [ __ ]
like going crazy in koreatown and
and then my mom who's in another car
calls me and she's like
get that guy over to her house for
dinner i want to cook for him
and i go mom you [ __ ] think we all
know each other
you know that [ __ ] guy you know that
guy mom
just cause i'm a a korean in the
entertain i don't know
all of them she's like you know stephen
yoon he was in
uh okja ocha he knows
[ __ ] you mom the [ __ ] off like
your mom's even more racist but my dad
he likes that [ __ ] he's very prideful
he's a prideful korean guy
except he was born in china oh wow so
during the you know war times
he's you know he's korean but he was
born in china he was on the run
and when i like to [ __ ] with my dad i
grabbed him by the neck and i go hey you
chinese [ __ ]
ching chong [ __ ] is it racist i
don't know
no i don't think i grab my dad by the
neck he's ver
he's one of the most prideful korean
people and i and
we're not going anywhere we're sitting
at the lights and i go [ __ ] did it
man
what you know i'm having a uh you know
connection with my dad i go
you ching chong chinese [ __ ]
came to america
in the 70s he's like yeah there was no
traffic then i go yeah just let me
[ __ ]
let me let me let me tell my story
you come here they try to [ __ ] burn
you out of koreatown they burn your
[ __ ] shop down
they call you [ __ ] they call you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you come here with nothing
you're working on an assembly line
you're poor you have you raised three
boys you have no [ __ ] money
and look at us now parasite [ __ ]
[ __ ] parasite dave chang best [ __ ]
chef in america
roy choi [ __ ] kpop dominating
dominating the [ __ ] um bobby lee
bobby lee
steve lee like we're kimchi on the menu
everywhere now everywhere every eric you
want some kimchi pizza you want some
probiotics probiotic [ __ ] up in your gut
you know like
everywhere this tiny [ __ ] country in
korea you know my dad's getting pumped
up he's like yeah
we [ __ ] did it man and all the texts
are still coming yes
there's a there's a racist uh what the
[ __ ] the term
it's called a perpetual foreigner where
it doesn't matter
that you i was born in los angeles that
you always feel like
a foreigner growing up the message from
my parents was
don't piss off the white people like we
need to act in a way
that's uh what's the other one model
minority we need to
we can't do anything that like upsets
them
because we might get sent back on the
boat you know it's like
you need to act in a certain way you
have to dress a certain way you have to
comb your
hairs you have to get a certain kind of
job doctor lawyer doctor lawyer
and you need to act that [ __ ] way
because we don't want to get sent back
and so yes yes father yes honorable
father
so i'm sitting there and i'm feeling
myself i'm feeling my race i'm feeling
my dad
and i'm like i [ __ ] did it [ __ ]
man
everywhere kpop cape food tiny [ __ ]
country that's been
under attack for generations barbecue
[ __ ] dominating
now they'll like us now they'll let us
into the club now you know
and uh we haven't moved an inch
we're still sitting in traffic and he
goes
i would trade all of that for for us to
[ __ ] go home right now or beat this
traffic
all right whatever cut to academy awards
to what was that it was the academy
awards and then when was the
the quarantine two three months later
no traffic no traffic i can get to the
beach in 15 minutes from my house it
used to take an hour and a half
i go dad let's go to the beach let's get
the [ __ ] out of here sitting in the car
and you remember when the quarantine
first started
you saw families walking down like
entire families walking the dog
everything was closed like there was no
smog in l.a
we [ __ ] drive to the beach we're
almost there
at a red light and there's a guy walking
his dog with his kid
and i and i get a kind of mad dog kind
of vibe like he's staring at me and our
windows are down and i'm i don't know
i'm always talking really loud to my dad
because he's hard of hearing
and the light turns green and he just he
like with
like disdain and disgust he just goes
like this he pulls his eyes back
he made he did the shingles yeah he did
the the did that to you
and your dad and i can sit here
and call tough guy from the [ __ ] that
guy i got a thick skin
and maybe because it was i was with my
dad and i love my dad
um and i i saw that my dad saw him do
that
and i was like like [ __ ] man like
and i froze i froze i was like
my dad is that that's wise that's wise
i mean he's with this [ __ ] kid and i
go listen it doesn't matter
you never know if you go over and engage
some guy in a physical confrontation and
he
beats you to death there's no comfort in
the fact that his kid was there to watch
you have to really people are so
flippant
about engaging in in physical violence
it's very [ __ ] dangerous it's
dangerous for everybody
especially you never know what someone
knows so i snap in those moments
i go to rage and like maybe if i was by
myself
maybe i would have been more
quick-witted and had a snappy comeback
but
someone hasn't done that to me the last
time someone did this to me
i was probably in a third world country
15 20 years ago and before that maybe i
was a
in in grade school and as a 44 year old
man who's in a lot of pain that's been
working on himself to heal
it like hurt me well
[ __ ] that guy just just get away from
him that's the best
you're not going to fix them by beating
the [ __ ] out of them you're not going to
change anything
you can i mean the idea that you're
going to punish him for that and it's
going to no it's going to make him hate
asian people more he's just a [ __ ] up
dude and a guy would do that to you for
no reason at all just sees you and wants
to hurt you and make you feel bad
that kind of guy is hurting man he's
probably been abused his whole life
there's probably something real wrong
with him he's probably had a [ __ ] up
alcoholic dad or something or
some uncle did something to him that's
always something
people that lash out and try to hurt
people randomly for no reason are
all in pain you know is that old
expression hurt people
hurt people definitely and that's true
and i'm hurt
yeah but you're but that's not a that's
an intelligent thing
to do nothing because you're paused
your pause is wise because you can call
it freezing
but you're stuck in an unwinnable
situation if you go over and beat that
guy's ass
like that is violence it's dangerous you
never know how it's going to turn out
you never know if he has a gun or a
knife or
[ __ ] i go darker than that kill him kill
him i go darker than that [ __ ] him just
beat up his kid in front of him oh jesus
i mean i don't think he would let you do
that then he would really kill you
but the the idea is that
the best thing to do is get the [ __ ] out
of there so the freezing and trying to
figure out what
because it's a it's a real decision if
you run over it but if you get the [ __ ]
out of there then that guy hurts you
and then you feel bad you never feel
like you got him back but growing up in
the 80s
i got that all the time and i and i
built up a thick skin to that and i was
i was like i'm going to go to a new
black school i'm going to go to all
mexican school and they're going to make
fun of me they're going to do that
they're going to call me mr miyagi there
so i pulled into the beach parking lot
and
my dad had just already deleted it from
he's like i was like
sorry dad and he's like i'm like what
the [ __ ] am i apologizing he's like yeah
whatever
and um and you know i'm saying it with
my whole chest korean
i was feeling very braggadocious and
proud and it all
it like deflates and i go
parasite got us here and then a virus
sends us right our dick shriveled back
into our body
and i'm like oh [ __ ] dude well that is a
virus too
well yeah that guy is a virus well look
it's like like that's that guy caught
that from somewhere well it's
our leadership they're calling they're
calling us they're calling it a 40 year
old man
and that's that's who it is it brought
it back he's not gonna
no that guy probably has always been
like that man it but it's like
people are inspiring right if you
inspire hate then people become
if they have that in you it brings it
back out and i think by just him saying
that it's a chinese virus dude when he
called it chinese
virus when he called it kung fu and not
correcting it the violence towards him
he didn't call it kung flu
he didn't well if he did he didn't say
it publicly i don't know if he said that
but he like there's all those things
showing that he crossed it out and he
still he says chinese
chinese virus right the little kid got
stabbed
at the sam's club in texas an asian kid
and violence and you know it's
asians don't speak up we don't ask for
help
we [ __ ] store it inside and then we
explode
so a little kid got stabbed look it up
uh
no i believe it right so because just
because he was asian
just because he was asian because of the
chinese flu comment
what trump they they did a thing where
they measure it every time he calls it
chinese virus
the violence towards asians goes up in
this country really yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy oh he did say it
yeah oh jesus that's crazy because
remember that lady in the white house
was saying
i heard someone in your administration
called it the kung flu
right and he was like remember he was
like what yeah
so he was pretending he didn't know what
but he had already said it he unless
that was after that
i think this was after that event this
was after that
so he's like that's a good name the kung
flu i'm gonna use it he said and this
thing where he was saying is like people
call lots of names there's lots of names
right coronavirus right kung flu yes
kung flu yeah he said a bunch of times
well there's been a lot of viruses named
after other places like the spanish flu
which killed
a [ __ ] shitload but if someone shows
you the stats and they're like look
yeah you choosing the words you want
right now is causing violence towards
asian people in this country and he's
like yeah [ __ ] him you know i don't
think he's uh that insightful right i
don't think he's thinking about it [ __ ]
trump anyone else that's saying that
right it's like
no but i'm saying like that maybe
someone needs to say it that way
because you saying it that way and um i
didn't know
that there was a stat that showed that
violence against asian people
went up every time he said it then it
makes that
first of all it has a name right yes
coronavirus covid19 it has name to call
it anything other than that name
it should either be funny or descriptive
now if he calls it the wuhan virus
that's really technically where it's
from
right i don't think there's anything
wrong with that but
the problem is actual racism and actual
violence that's the real problem
now the other thing is when you're a
leader that's when things get slippery
because then you can't just just be a
regular person because if you're a
leader
you literally can help other people
like you don't maybe he doesn't even
realize it but you really can change the
way people think and behave when
when a really powerful person like him
right the most powerful in the country
arguably
when he says something that
prescribes unity that that that
promotes the idea of companionship and a
friendship
of love and of support and camaraderie
literally can change the way people feel
and also if he says something hateful
it'll change the way people feel like we
move
whether we like it or not there's so
many of us there's 300 million in this
country plus
and we move to inspirational words or
angry words that's you man
that's you you are an inspiration like
you when you say things like that
people listen you see how people are if
you wanted we were joking right now but
if you did start a cult
there'd be [ __ ] millions of people
signing up tomorrow and they would
listen to you
and if you said this is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
these chinese people
then they'd say we're we're with joe you
know i don't know
i think most one would leave me if i
said that they would be smart enough
kanye fell over and tupac come on tupac
stay with us bro
this kanye one does not want to stand up
it's so ironic
so this is what i need help with okay
how fast did i answer the phone
when you called me the other day like it
was like a normal
it's it's like the first i i weren't we
texting first
texting first but then when you called
me i'm so thirsty
that people people assume right
in our in our workaholic culture people
assume that you must be really busy i
mean you actually are busy
i'm not busy i don't have anything going
on
like when someone calls me i make it a
game now
like here's another thing i don't want
to admit to you like i pulled up right
here i was sitting outside for an hour
i was sitting in a uh like i was talking
to this homeless guy outside for an hour
before i pulled in here
and um so when someone calls me now
i you know it's cool to let it ring
three times i'm like boom i do the same
thing
i just answer so i don't got anything
going on listen i know i know in our
culture it's really cool to be like
hey bro what project you're working on
what are you doing i'm like nothing
i'm working on myself that's what i'm
working on now that's really cool yeah
so i
i i take my dog i got a rescue from
costa rica
i love my dog and i go on walks with my
dog now
that are so long that my dog looks at me
and is like dude when the [ __ ] are we
gonna go back home
and i'm walking and i'm smelling i'm
taking in my neighborhood i'm smelling
the petunias i literally
stop to smell the roses i go this is my
life now i stop to smell the roses
i walk to this underpass where there's
like the entire homeless community
i um you know i give them snacks clean
underwear
water i just talk to them and they see
me coming they're like oh there's that
[ __ ] guy that's gonna talk to us for
like
six hours again and then i'm really busy
today dave uh
sam don't we got like a one o'clock
brunch you know
and and this is my life now not much
going on
and and and you got to tell me all this
just because you answered the phone
quick
like no i'm not i'm trying to set you
well i'm trying to set up how soft i am
that's not so i'm not hard i don't have
i'm not on it okay i'm not on it let me
pause you for a second okay let me
help you out here first of all if you
just stat sat there
and you weren't busy and just stared at
your phone and let it ring three times
you'd be a [ __ ] idiot
but people do that there's people idiots
you should you should record them
everyone should have like a secret video
of your friends staring at the phone
deciding whether or not to talk to you
or whether or not to let it ring three
times
you you see the phone ring and you pick
it up right away yeah if i can
you don't do that you don't do cool guy
like no let me
i'm not cool guy someone calls me i'm
like what's up jamie
first ring first tell my friends i miss
him i tell him i love him i'm not cool
guy i answer the phone
i'm not i'm i'm thirsty desperate as
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't even think
it rang
my game that i play is that i try to i
try to pick it up before it even rings
once
it's like like like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is telepathic
if someone butt dials me i call them
right back so my point is
i don't i don't got much going on i'm
working on myself
i'm i'm trying to stop and and be
present and enjoy things
and i'm having a great day beautiful
this is this happened last week by the
way
walking back home like i've been gone
for like two and a half hour walk
i'm walking back home once again i'm at
a red light
car pulls up window comes down and
i'm just sitting there and i get that
feeling that something's about to happen
and the light turns you know on the
other crossing light turns uh
it's about to turn red and he goes hey
hey hey and i look over and he goes
go back to where you come from what do i
got
seven seconds before you know like i got
a few seconds
and i go once again this to go back this
is the second incident since the
pandemic started and i go i got this i
know this one people used to say that to
me
[ __ ] and like there's there's like if
you if you
asian people that are born in america go
back to where you come from bellflower
whittier garden grove like that's
and i and i and i froze again i go
i have this uh come back clap back
whatever
i have that and i go joe will know what
to say he's a comedian he's on stage
with hecklers
the best thing you'd say to someone like
that is stare at him but he's gone
already
luke is a [ __ ] let him go like mad dog
stare gorgeous
empty blank you're a mirror
doesn't mean anything go back to where
you come from the guy's a [ __ ]
again like why why would he yell out at
you you're not an argument with this
person
he's a piece of [ __ ] he sees you on the
side of the road and just yells out at
you
again guarantee you that guy was abused
his life sucks
go back to where you come from that's a
crazy thing to say to people
and then it's like what my mom's [ __ ]
buddy your mom's [ __ ]
do i go offensive or do i go
self-suffocated [ __ ] everybody
is from somewhere else this is the place
unless you're [ __ ] cherokee
unless you're a native american so the
best comeback for that is just stare
down
just nothing just give him nothing you
want to argue with the guy then he gets
out and beats your ass
yeah he threw my whole [ __ ] day off i
i went home
i put i i laid down on my bed and i was
like god damn
that's what he wanted to do you know and
i go when was the last time i got that
high school high school some persian
kids said go back to where you're going
twice since the pandemic and all from
from high school on always out of red
lights maybe i should just
maybe i should just run the wrench maybe
we should just roll the windows up and
just
look straight and and there's gonna be
[ __ ]
this get look life is an unfair game
it's
unfair it's unfair with
your mind like the the idea that
everybody has the same mind is
ridiculous
i know my mind is dog [ __ ] compared to
elon musk's i've talked to him
everybody has different different
attributes every has
everybody has different environment
everyone has different family life
genetics influences abuse
assaults different things that have
happened to you that have been
horrible that you've had to get through
you know the loss of loved ones all
these different things they vary
so much from person to person we have a
rough idea of what it means
if your mom dies when you're five we
have a rough idea we have a rough idea
if it means if you got beat up when you
were 13 in front of your girlfriend we
have a rough idea
right we don't know until we experience
it and everybody experiences a different
[ __ ] hand of cards
and then here you find yourself you know
whatever
age you are in life just still battling
demons from your childhood and all
[ __ ] up from things that have been
happening to you
and you you've never had a good path
your [ __ ] brain doesn't work that
good
you've never had a thing that you do
that makes you feel special
right when you paint and you get
rewarded for that painting and people
love it there's a charge
there's a thing some people don't have a
thing they ain't got [ __ ]
and that kind of person sees you on the
side
of them at a red light and says go back
to where you come from and that gets
into your head and it [ __ ] you up
that's what they want to do they want
you to feel what they feel when someone
says something hateful
one of the reason why it works is
because like you feel
their hate it's like it comes off of
them like
you get it on your system and that's one
of the ways like men intimidate other
men
when men are angry and scream at men and
get in their face one when
they're doing is they're not just
puffing their chest out they're not
just signaling that they're aggressive
and violent they're getting their hate
in you you have to feel it you feel it
like a drug
like if someone's mad at you you feel
and it's all about how much tolerance
you have to that drug
of other people's aggression and anger
and resentment and jealousy and all the
the various toxic emotions that people
have when someone's
at you yet like if you i'm sure you've
dated crazy women right
and i don't even have to ask so there's
a moment in time
when a crazy girl is yelling at you and
they're mad at you and like jesus christ
you're making me crazy
it's getting into me like you're crazy
is on me
it's like i gotta get out of here it's
[ __ ] contagious
and like a virus it can change the way
you feel
and if you're in a [ __ ] hive just
like a if you're in like uh just a hot
spot
of nasty thinking and behavior
you grow up in that maybe you have
abusive family maybe your
dad beats your mom and your mom beats
you and you beat your brother and your
brother beats your sister it's just
[ __ ] madness and then you have
neighbors that suck too and everybody
sucks
and that's as much of a virus as the flu
it's a it's a mind virus that gets out
into the other people that around you
and you could be real lucky
and you could live in a uh in an area
of uh mind nature a peaceful valley with
a beautiful mountain and a creek that
goes through it
and that's the that's the community that
you're in you got lucky
you grew up in a wonderful community
with fantastic parents and great
neighbors and your
your aunt your uncle come over and
everybody has good times and
oh sure there's a little bit of hardship
here and there but for the most part
people love each other it's the [ __ ]
it's not fair right it's not fair
when that guy yells out at you like that
man it's hard to internalize all this
in the moment because you are feeling
his hate well i'll tell you tell you
what happens
i go i i become jealous of
comedians because when i'm at a comedy
show and i see hecklers and i'm like
that guy was so quick with that comeback
yeah but i won't do that in real life oh
i don't do that in real life really no
some guy cuts you off you don't have a
fast one ready no
no but you know what it
so i reflect on it when i go home and i
go what did i say the last time this
happened
and then i started laughing because it
was high school
a guy said hey why don't you go back to
you know we got an argument he goes hey
why don't you just go back to where you
come from
uh i go home i'm like oh [ __ ] but it's a
learned thing
years went by years went by the guy was
a senior in high school
and i said i got it i got it complete
the revenge is the best
dish serve cold or all that like not for
comedy
i see him in class and i and i get my
balls up and i go
i got it completely out of context four
years later right your mom's [ __ ]
the guy's like what the [ __ ] that's
where i come from and i just walked away
and i go
that that landed so flat like that not
really though
because think about it right now we're
laughing like it's a slow burn
a four a joke delivered four years later
worse
even worse a joke delivered four years
later and talked about 15 years later
see see now it's effective
it's just a real slow bomb
hurt whenever i see stuff like that
i i go
because i grew up with it if if you know
when you're in high school and people go
hey pick a superpower invisibility or
flight
right i'm already invisible like being
an asian
and growing up in the communities that i
grew up with i was invisible like
i don't even have a voice like you might
find this hard to believe but
i never talked growing up i was the kid
in the corner
and like girls would form groups and
talk about which guy they want to [ __ ]
and
i wouldn't even be they're like dave's
sitting right there and they're like
yeah
he's not even he's not even on the
[ __ ] roster
and i'm like so i i i go wait
is this racist yeah but what has it
how can i turn this around what it did
for me
the asian superpower is
if you're not seen and you're not heard
and we're seen as non-threatening
i can go anywhere i can go anywhere
and people open up to me i've been to
the congo i've been to third world
countries i've been to
every [ __ ] state in in america i
might be the most american person like
i've been to every [ __ ] state i've
hitchhiked from the time i was 15 to
every [ __ ] state every country and
i've
talked and and because would a black guy
be able to do that
would a white guy be able to do that
when people see
oh that guy's chinese he's like jackie
chan or he's uh
whatever they think they don't think
that i'm gonna do anything or say
anything or i'm gonna
you know pose any threat so they just
open up and they say the most
i don't know like when i started
hitchhiking people said
no one's gonna pick you up right like
60s 70s everyone hitchhiked and then
something weird happened in the 80s
where like you're going to get raped
kidnapped murdered you know
but i go i don't think so i think if i
put my thumb out
and ask for help someone's going to give
it to me and with that i got to see the
world for free
i got to go everywhere and
much like what happened was i would sit
shotgun
and i'm getting these free rides and two
things would happen either the driver
has a long drive and they want someone
to talk to
or they want me to talk to them and
something would happen and like i'm in
the car right now with a complete
stranger
anything could happen and the first hour
is always
small talk how long you been on the road
what would you do you know it's all that
kind of stuff
something switches when they know the
rides about like i'm about to get out or
whatever
i'm never going to see this guy again
i'm never going to see this guy again
so now we've been talking about new
sports and weather for an hour
last 10 minutes i [ __ ] my sister when
i was 12.
whoa everything comes out so i've heard
think about how many rides how was he he
was 12 how old was his sister
i don't know eight i mean everything
drugs
incest you know i i killed somebody
like murder a guy called murder
confessions really i've heard
the most insane hold one at a time
murder confession
i don't know if i shouldn't retell it
you definitely should be
a guy confessed to me that he was
thinking of raping me
when i stayed at his house oh jesus you
stayed at his house
you didn't just hitchhike you
hitchhoused i was in uh
i was in the deep south i was in the
deep south
it was like my i was trying to hitchhike
from la to to new york city
i was with my friend brian same thing no
one's going to pick up two
two [ __ ] dudes and john wayne picks
us up
cowboy guy what a 10 gallon hat
you know damn you boys look you know
hot out there get in the car and he's
telling us about
shrimp po boys and you know he's just
he works on a um offshore offshore oil
rig
and uh it's uh two weeks on two weeks
off and it's just two weeks off right
now
so he's like where are you guys headed
and we're like we're trying to get to
new york new york
but you want to go there for a bunch of
queers out there i don't know we just we
want to check it out
you guys want to stay at my house
tonight like this guy looks like grandpa
just cowboy boots cowboy hat just
big gut like he's a dude right
yeah i'm young i'm 17 or 18 at this time
we get to his house and uh
oh [ __ ] this is what i'm talking about
tiny town in uh
louisiana deep south like
we get in his house die hard movie
collection rambo movie collection
shotguns and uh
lube just just just the dude just a
man's man
and he has uh and his side in his
part-time job as an anesthesiologist
but part-time anesthesia part-time
medicine and then
part-time offshore or oil rig
and uh i'm you know this is summertime
deep south covered with like grease and
mosquitoes living outside on the road
hitchhiking he's like you guys want to
take a shower
i'm like [ __ ] yeah i'm the first one in
the shower
and uh and then i come out i got the
towel wrapped on
he's like he made us like a frozen pizza
or something
and there's a protest on the television
it's uh
sanford this this is 1993 or 94.
there's a protest of uh something with
gay people in
in san francisco and they were
protesting
and he's watching it i'm like what he's
like
i'm queer you never see me out there
protesting and i'm like
oh [ __ ] and then he and then my friend
brian who's covered in
grease and dirt he hasn't showered yet
and i'm like oh [ __ ] and i started
getting my clothes on
and uh you know it's one thing to be gay
and then it's one thing to be
picked up by like a you know a big gay
guy with a cowboy hat
takes it to his house so and and
and i here's the thing i don't want to
discourage people from hitchhiking this
is
one weird incident that's happened in
like 15 years of hitchhiking
so he's like hey hey brian why don't you
it's your turn why don't you take a
shower
i know i'm okay i'm all right you're
filthy once you get in there
take a shower he's like nah nah i'm all
right i'm okay
and i go oh [ __ ] what do we do you know
i
do a little pow-wow in the corner he's
like he's old
we can take him if he tries anything
we're tired we were [ __ ] so
tired we're like he's he looks like he
was like falling asleep on his
on his couch and he goes uh
he's gonna go to sleep soon let's just
[ __ ] stay the night
it's [ __ ] air-conditioned in here and
then let's leave first thing in the
morning before he wakes up like okay
[ __ ] it let's just do it
all right boys i'm gonna turn in like
yes so we
we take the couch and i go let's sleep
in a formation
and let's take turns you stick we should
have just left
you go you you stay up for an hour and
then wake me up i'll stay up for an hour
we'll just and then we'll leave
crack of dawn you know um
i had a pocket knife so i slept like
this i took the knife
and i put a thing like this and i slept
like that
and i stayed up for the first hour and i
see his him walking around his room and
the lights are on
and i'm like this this guy is not going
to sleep midnight one in the morning
he's still i'm like what the [ __ ]
why won't this guy go to sleep putting
his masks on
so i nudged brian i go hey it's your
turn i got
i got him i'm gonna [ __ ] pass out
he's out cold
i'm like [ __ ] dude [ __ ] man
i'm too tired and i go
okay i'm just gonna stay up the whole
night so i'm up i'm like
guys are closing bringing back up again
gripping the knife
and then sometime around 5 30 in the
morning or something
my eyes are closed but you know when you
feel someone so
he comes out of his room and he's
standing there and i could see and then
i
oh [ __ ] and then i grip the knife and i
go this is it this is it it's going to
happen right now
and he just leaves he goes out the door
and i go oh [ __ ] like
and then i wake up brian i go brian
let's get the [ __ ] out of here he's like
what
what's going on he's like dude he just
left he's like okay i'm gonna take a
shower then
i'm like what are you talking about he's
like if he went to the store or
something like
he's not gonna get some ducks yeah he's
not gonna be back for a little let me
i'll just jump in and jump i go dude
let's just go right now like
he was i don't know if he was jerking
off or what like he was i had my eyes
closed but he was standing right there
and he's like i'll be
i'll be quick so he runs in
takes a fast shower we get our clothes
on and like just as we're walking out
he's like
hey he's he like pulls in you guys are
leaving without saying bye
i just went to the market to get some
eggs for breakfast and i'm like
oh [ __ ] dude so i'm like i have no knife
in my hand the whole time i go
uh like it's that that uh thing where i
i'm a people pleaser
you know like i'll even put my own life
at risk to like this guy went to the
store and got eggs for me you know
like uh yeah sure we'll have some eggs
so we go in
and the guy starts talking about
um his wife and how um he works on this
offshore oil rig with like a younger
dude it's just two guys running this
whole oil rig
and the other guy just talks about how
much he hates gay people the whole time
not knowing that this guy is wow and um
and then he just like like uh like all
the other times i've been picked up it
starts opening up about how
he was married he has a bunch of
children and then he figured out he was
gay
and uh and then he was like i could see
it he he knows we're on our way out he's
never going to see us
let's just [ __ ] let it off you you
boys look so cute on the side of the
road
there last night and it was like i was
so like
i'm so lonely i i don't get to you know
you don't know what it's like to be a
queer guy in in the deep south
and uh man i when i came out this
morning and i saw you guys sleeping
together
you guys on the couch you look so
beautiful and perfect and i'm like
oh my [ __ ] god dude
and then he says i thought about just
you know
if you guys wouldn't mind if i just
touched you a little bit
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and you know
we've once again i froze i'm like oh
yeah yeah cool
yeah so i'm and so i said yeah we're
gonna we're gonna leave now
so we just [ __ ] booked it and then um
all of his neighbors were
black like he lived like in a black
neighborhood and like the houses are on
stilts
because of the swampland and whatever
and i don't know if he's done this
before but as we ran out
like i heard like the kids laughing and
they're like oh tom they're trying to do
it again or and i'm like oh [ __ ] like
this isn't the first time like
of course and um look man
this is looking for hitchhikers i've
hitched all over the world
that was the only time right and yeah
and and so
i i highly recommend it but
um yeah what i was saying about being
invisible
is a lot of times people will do
this or say come go back to where you
come from because they're like this
fucker's not gonna do anything
and that's just not the way the world
works
you know like someone was explaining to
me the other day that no one ever wins a
war
i go what are you talking about we come
in we blow [ __ ] up and then we take the
it's like if you look at
germany and japan right there's two
countries that are very small you look
at a globe and you look at how small
they are
these are two countries that are very
tiny that have tried to dominate
every country around them and japan has
started you know
they germany starts every world war
right and so you're like oh but we won
those wars
but we drive their cars now we drive
lexus we drive
they want in the end and then you think
of the soldiers that come home
the ptsd the drug addiction the
homelessness
it's like look at our country now it's
like did we win
like you won like on the charts you look
at the numbers we took this town we did
this we did that
and
when you [ __ ] with people when you hurt
someone
it stays with them forever like it stays
with them for a long time
unless you have tools and different
things to like
work through those things which i i i've
been working on
a lot but yeah being
oh [ __ ] that's sort of racist that no
one really thinks of me as a threat
how can i turn that to an advantage i'm
gonna travel the entire world
i'm gonna train hop i'm gonna hitchhike
um
vice gaming like one of the first vice
shows was thumbs up
i i uh gavin mcinnes uh
shane smith those guys i used to i've
been writing and drawing that's how i
found out about you
really yeah i found out about you from
well from two places one from bourdain
but two from a video that i watch of you
going to the congo
looking for a dinosaur that was the
first thing i ever saw of you i think
that's like then i talked to bourdain
about you
and he was like you got to talk to this
guy
and when i saw your show i was like look
at this dude this is crazy he's looking
for a [ __ ] brontosaurus in the middle
of the congo
in 1994 i was living in israel in a farm
called ramat hakovesh and it was a
kibbutz
and to live on the kibbutz you have to
work and i was the
illegal immigrant there so i'm trying i
have no money
so i'm making enough working on the farm
just to live on the farm
and at this point i'm 18 years old i've
been hitchhiking since i was 15
and i've seen the whole world i've
hitchhiked through europe i've
hitchhiked through
the u.s back and forth and i'm bored
this isn't 19 i'm like what you go to
the eiffel tower
you take that same like this right where
what haven't we done yet
we've been it's all mapped out we've
been to everywhere we've seen everything
we've done everything
i'm a i have a heart of a of an explorer
i want to find new things you know
and so i'm living on this kibbutz most
of the other people that are from
australia and south africa and what i
love about them is they're so racist
that they don't even know they're racist
like i'm the only asian guy there and
they're like nintendo sega genesis like
they i'm like i got a name and they're
like
no your name is nintendo i'm like okay
and so i'm working illegally in a casino
illegally at a wedding catering place
and then working on this farm
so i have three jobs i'm making like you
know under the table
and there's a a library on the farm of
books that have been left behind by past
travelers
and of course there's a old from the 70s
or 80s a national geographic catalog
and i start reading about mokele membe i
don't know if that's how you say it but
it's
scientists national geographic people
have spotted this [ __ ]
brontosaur-like thing
in the congo and and it's still there
and the congo is still
it's the heart of darkness and i gotta
[ __ ] find this thing
i gotta go there like i i was i was how
old were you at the time i was 18. you
decided you were going to go there i was
like i have to go there how old were you
when you went
18 years old oh no no and then vice i'll
i'll bring it back to how that turned
into vice but so i
i get on a plane and tons of lying and
manipulating to get the visa because it
wasn't open to tourism it was only open
for
business and so i i make up the story
that i'm a i'm a
bodyguard to a toothpaste executive and
i work day and night to get a ticket to
the congo
and there's no tickets it's this airline
aeroflot and i'm in
israel which is close to africa but
because it's this russian airline
i get on this flight it goes to moscow
and then
malta and then like six other african
countries and then it lands in
brazil how long like three days almost
like
like in like a shaky airplane you know
and and
you know everyone in there is the ones
that got to get out
right so when they're coming back
they're bringing chickens and goats and
all kinds of [ __ ] on the plane and wow
it smells like [ __ ]
and i don't know this is pre-internet
right i
i don't have any information on the
congo except for i heard that there's a
dinosaur there what year
94 94 95 i i lost track of time but it
was
right after high school so eighteen so
no you don't have a cell phone either
no cell phone nothing and
the second i get off the plane it smells
horrible
because it's just burning trash
everywhere and it's hot and it's
oppressive
and i go what the [ __ ] am i doing here
like why am i here and everyone there
asked me what are you doing here
they don't speak english they speak
french i didn't know that
they're in the middle of a civil war uh
i think the two factions were called the
ninjas and the cobras
like little kids shooting at night the
every third bullet is like a tracer
bullet
so it looks like fireworks like what is
that they're like oh they're just
shooting into the air
first breakout of ebola malaria
and people go why did you do that
it's not normal behavior and i go
the l.a riots happened in 1992. i
watched
normal civilization normal civilized
manners you know this is how people are
you go to a store
i saw that crumble overnight in one
night it went from
[ __ ] you everything let's burn down
let's rob
pillage steal everything i go oh it
could happen that fast
and once again that same kind of oh i
think i'm accepted in this
country i think people like me for me
and it's like no we don't want you get
the [ __ ] go back to where you come from
so i think you know and i could go on
and on about all the traumas i've
experienced in my life but i
heard people hurt people i was in a lot
of pain i was like i i didn't like
korean people
i didn't like myself i didn't like i'd
experienced a lot of
a lot of abuse from black people and i
just wanted to
i didn't know anything there was no
internet i didn't like i felt like an
alien i i'm like i don't belong anywhere
i just so i would go
everyone go don't go to bosnia don't go
to the congo don't go to the gaza strip
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go
every [ __ ] place my life has been
very reactionary
right my life has been like you don't
tell me what to do
you don't tell me how to podcast i'm
gonna stick a butt plug in my you know
right i'm gonna do
what you know so i'm in the congo
and it's in a full-blown war
there's people being um uh we and
everyone's like
who are you oh my god who is this blonde
asian here
like i had my hair dyed done too and
they
and so i could go and tell a million
stories about the congo but at some
point
why you were looking for this
brontosaurus for real or you just wanted
to go to the congress one
as well what i i know the kids like to
say 100 percent
i've heard you say it too yeah why not
99 just to leave one percent
99 i was there for the dinosaur like
like i was so young and dumb and stupid
and ignorant where
i truly truly thought i was gonna find
it
like i i didn't know enough about like
the everything made sense to me because
anyone listening to this right now we're
talking about a story from
20 years ago right right i was a stupid
kid
i believed in santa claus very late you
know like i i was a bedwetter
i'm [ __ ] up man so when i finally did
get to the jungle i got out of
brazzaville i got up and i got to
um this jungle area called hueso
then i believed because the spiders are
this big
and the frogs are this big and how big
are the frogs
just everything is looks insane the
snakes they got snakes out here this big
like it was like okay now i believe like
every year
scientists were finding a new species of
something that they thought was gone
and i'm like okay the and and it's
and then and then i and then i meet the
pygmies whoa
and and that was ah [ __ ] i don't know
what version of the story i should tell
because it gets so dark
i met a german guy named [ __ ] i
shouldn't say his name
i met a german guy there who was the
same age as me
and he could this is in the city and
then he could tell that i was lost
i didn't know who this guy was he was
being groomed to be like the next big
politician in frankfurt or something
right and so i didn't i didn't get this
until later but he was here as his like
sex vacation to [ __ ] as many black he
liked black women
so he's gonna [ __ ] as many
curb your language dave to have as many
intimate
relations with women as possible is that
better
no the other i'm trying i'm trying to be
better for myself
that's what i'm trying and the way it
was better you're explaining what it was
it's not a bad thing that's that's what
he was doing so i figured out so he sees
me as another
bad thing to explain things accurately
you know
you could use other words though yeah
but that's what it is right
it is what it is but i i
i can i can come off i can turn people
off when i use that language
i want who are these people um
people that don't like you no no they're
people that they want dave no swear
dave i came here for g rated dave and i
want my mom
to try to be g rated i'm just trying to
pg 13 dave
that's what i was signing up for
occasionally the word [ __ ]
pg-13 they have like rules right like
two shits
99 okay so i'm with
you thought that there was a real
dinosaur in there and when you got there
and you saw the big frogs and the big
snakes
i'm like maybe it is yeah maybe it is
and
what happens is we we go to the last
spotting of it
right and then i meet is there any
evidence at all
like everyone i talked to oh yeah yeah
we've seen it
like there's no like no that's crazy
every [ __ ] person i meet is like
oh yeah it's in in the last so is it one
of those things where
realistically there's not a whole lot of
people looking for it anyway
no but there are scientists that go out
there and in the meantime
i've never seen anyone murdered before
until i got here right i've been through
the early riots i've seen things
broken and burned down and guns pointed
but i've never seen anyone hung
i've never seen anyone stoned to death
and and it's
absolute chaos i'm seeing people
murdered i'm scared for my life i got
attacked one time
so i go i need to find now i have to
find this dinosaur
and i also know that there's a chance
that i might never go home again
so i write a letter to my parents they
don't know where i am they think i'm in
israel on this farm
like i didn't tell anybody so i wrote my
parents this long letter of
i love you guys i'm about to embark on a
journey to find a dinosaur
and i sent it at the airport before i
got on the plane to the jungle
i have no money i have only one change
of clothes i have [ __ ] blonde hair
and i i go into the jungle and we get
lost
immediately i'm a [ __ ] city boy what
the hell do i know about the jungle
what do i know about the jungle did you
have any direction
nothing i just i just knew what
you know you know what when i landed in
the jungle there was a guy
that i think i want to say his name is
chris that was a peace corps guy
and he was there to help build welds in
uh this bantu village
and he said the place what you guys are
looking for he's like it's a
you're not gonna find a dime you know he
was like the reasonable one
and i go how do i know if you don't try
you know i still believed i still wanted
to believe
i was willing to risk my life for it
so we get i haven't [ __ ] told this
story in so long so we get to the jungle
and and we start walking there's a minor
trail
and then it disappears it's just gone
and i'm like we're [ __ ]
lost in the jungle we're lost in the
jungle so
i'm with this guy that
the the what we told people he was here
to
[ __ ] as many women as possible but we
went with the story of
he is the toothpaste executive and i'm
his bodyguard
that's a fake [ __ ] story right as
we're lost in the jungle
he starts to think that story is real
hey go fetch
me a pineapple i go dude i'm not sure
he's like
you're not a real executive bro like i'm
not gonna get and he starts like
telling me like like i'm like hey you
know that was a fake story right like
he's like
and there's no one around so we get lost
for days
and he starts to really be like
humiliating towards me
and right on my nerves and
we had rations we went in with some
crackers and some like tuna
in a can thing and i go hey man we're
[ __ ] lost
i don't know how to survive we need to
ration this food out i come he ate it
all
he ate it all
wow and and and and now like
have you ever been in that kind of
situation where you're like i'm gonna
die here like i'm never gonna like
hope is gone like i'm in a thick thick
congolese jungle like i don't know how
to get out
and we've been lost for days like i
don't know how to survive
i don't [ __ ] know how to like i i
this is it
you know it's insane and on top of it i
have this [ __ ] german [ __ ] who's
like talking down to me
making fun of me and eating my [ __ ]
rations
like i would pump all the [ __ ] water
and put the the water purification
tablets and be like thanks
and i'm like dude what the [ __ ] man like
that i did all that work so we could
share it and so he was just
he was a dick and so man and you're
stuck in
you've been in a jungle like that before
no dude so we set up a tent we have one
tent and so we're
we're in close quarters with each other
at night the moon is like this [ __ ]
big
like it's humongous and you hear the
entire jungle come alive
what are like [ __ ] monkeys and like
things are bumping into the tent at
night like huge insects and like
and i'm like i'm i'm like i'm gonna die
here
i'm gonna die here so the few times in
my life where i've been in this kind of
hopeless situation
the only thing that's gonna get me out
of it is if i can control my mind
because if i because i'm fall i'm i'm
like falling into despair
and in the daytime i'm doing stand up to
the trees
because we're just walking in like
circles and i'm like hey how are you
guys doing all tonight you know so you
don't know where you are
i don't know where i am i'm talking to
the vegetation oh my god
and this guy is riding my last nerve and
he's
and so i could safely say i lost my mind
and so we're down to our last food
and he and he did it again and i said
bro what the [ __ ] did i tell you we got
to make this last i'm starving you ate
the rations that were supposed
that was it and he's like whatever and
he's he has a more like
dissociated like checked out like like
we'll get out of here somehow
and part of i don't know his coping
thing was to like talk down to me or
whatever
and so that night and we're we're lost
at this point a week and a half maybe
we haven't you know i'm [ __ ] 90
pounds i've lost all this weight
i'm gonna kill this guy i'm gonna murder
him i'm gonna [ __ ] murder him because
i don't like people talking [ __ ] to me
like that i don't like i've been a
punching bag for this guy for
for weeks now and i'm just gonna [ __ ]
kill him
and if i have to eat him to survive i
guess i'll do that
and so he's out cold he's got [ __ ]
crumbs on his face tuna [ __ ] juice
from the food that was supposed to be
shared
and i pick up i go outside the tent and
i pick up i pick up a huge rock like
bigger than this and i go i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this guy
i i have officially lost my mind
like i can't i'm barely gonna survive i
can't do it here with
this guy so he's out that's [ __ ]
looking at his face
and i pick up the rock and i go
just like i don't even have to apply any
pressure if i just drop it he's done
like he'll he'll be [ __ ] dead
and i go oh [ __ ] is there anything left
is there any common sense is there any
light left in my
and i uh
ah i
i gotta [ __ ] kill this guy he has to
go he has to he has to he has to die
he has to die he has to [ __ ] die
ah and then i just i didn't do it i'm
not a murderer
i can't like and in the mind
i'll do it i'll do i'll do what murder
dave come to the front
no one's ever gonna know he does his
family doesn't know he's there
your family nobody knows who you are
this guy chris the peace corps guy he's
not gonna [ __ ] say anything
you can kill him right now he has a ton
of cash that he hasn't been sharing with
you
you can get out of here you can [ __ ]
get some of your pride and your ego back
those [ __ ] guys treating you like a
[ __ ] like like a chinese waiter or
something
do it no one will ever know
no one will ever [ __ ] find out you
are you're probably going to die too
you want to die like [ __ ] catering to
this guy just do it
and i'm sitting no i don't i don't want
to i don't i'm not a murderer and
i didn't kill him i woke up the next day
and i'm just looking at him like
[ __ ] you don't even know
you don't even know what almost happened
last night we're walking around
hey what's that there's a [ __ ] pygmy
up one of those 200 100 foot trees he's
just sitting there chilling
and i go what is that is that a person
waves at us
200 feet above you huge tree like just i
don't know that's so high
it's so high it was so high how did you
spot him
he was he was like it was shaking a
little wow
from the place he was to get in front of
us was
seconds like hi it's like this short
what's this jungle that i mean when you
when you're in there do you even see
sunlight through it or is it just no
it's so dense i mean like yeah there's
some cracks but it's
just this was also in the national
geographic why that
the dinosaur would be here is because
cameras can't see it because it's such a
dense thick
forest and there's things in there that
are like moving and you know
dude your description sounds terrifying
it's terrible trying to sleep in the
tent
oh my god god dude i'm freaking out over
here
um so so the the um the guy comes up
he's this short he's like tiny
he's like you guys want some honey what
oh my god and um
this is this is where my skill
as an artist has got me out of so many
situations
right because if you're in if you're in
jail and you have any kind of skills
singing dancing telling jokes drawing
you're a celebrity
so this guy doesn't speak english we
don't speak whatever language he speaks
so i start drawing stuff like food like
you know
in the dirt and he's like oh yeah i got
you and he
and he and he goes and um he brings us
some meat that's all charred and i'm
like
i don't know what that is you know and
and i took one bite and it tastes
horrible and i'm like i'm gonna starve
to death but i can't eat that wow and so
it was like a movie he's like come on
come on we're walking and you know it's
us
like stumbling machete trying to he's
just like
like we get around a corner
entire village of pygmies they've never
[ __ ] seen an asian person before
i'm c3po and they're the ewoks from
blonde they're coming they're touching
my face they're like
yeah look it looks like he's like i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're saying
like um the kid keeps
doing this thing like uh i go what are
you saying
there was one older older guy in the
village that i guess spoke a tiny bit of
uh
french so my the german guy can
translate he's like
they're saying you come from the stars
you're coming from the stars
and i'm like oh my god that's heavy
so i'm like so i'm like we're saved they
bring us some honey they bring us some
fruit and i'm like oh god i'm like just
devouring it they're laughing at us
and you know it's like the national
geographic the women's tits are like
down to their ankles and um
this [ __ ] guy he's an alien he's an
alien i told you
1995 i was uh yeah i was 19 years old
yeah 19 years old wow yeah and and they
put that
um they put their clothes on for the
picture they were all naked when i got
in there wow
um look at my tivos
that's amazing that picture is amazing
so i um now had any of these people seen
it did you ever
describe it to them oh yeah so i draw
the dinosaur i go here's the dinosaur
and what were they saying they go oh
yeah yeah yeah there's never like no
it's always like
okay there's the dinosaur
and uh they go let's go and
i go they go it's it's through wetlands
like this
there's gonna be leeches like uh there's
a disease called bilharzia
where uh there's like uh snails under
like
still moving waters and the second a
mammal steps in the water
little [ __ ] parasites shoot off the
snail like uh like heat-seeking missiles
and they go
in your dick hole and then you piss and
[ __ ] blood till you die and i'm like
okay i'm done like i tap
so they're explaining like all the
the trek and the way to go find this
dinosaur
and i'm like and i went i went up until
the leeches
and then when i came out with the
leeches i go all right i like this this
is it
you know i go can you help us get out of
the jungle
and they're like it took less than a day
that's how close we were to like
really yeah we were probably [ __ ]
walking in circles
so we get out in less than a day i get
i get back home i'm 19 years old i start
writing for
uh for vice i start drawing pictures for
them i do comics i'm writing
and uh oh no i was writing for a
magazine called giant robot
and uh gavin and shane would read that
magazine and they're like
they were ahead of the curve right like
when all print magazine right
existed they were like
we need to go to digital like like they
were
you know vice has always been free
everyone feeds it they go to those
magazine shops or wherever and
yeah and they're like we need to have
online presence the internet was brand
new
and they said dave that is the [ __ ]
and i told you
not the pg-13 but that story gets very
dark
darker than what i said they go will you
go back
with a camera and a camera crew and i
said
that was one of the most traumatic i
almost died i saw people murdered there
was a [ __ ] virus where people were
bleeding out of their eyeballs
no okay i'll go enough time had passed
it was
10 years later actually it wasn't it was
that was uh
95 and then it was like eight or ten
years later
and um so that was the one that vice
filmed they're like can you go about
that photo for the mickey mouse shirt
that was earlier that was from when i
went with the film like just my camera
so i go back and um how did we even get
to this
the dinosaur the tightness
they all see this same dinosaur have you
[ __ ] look at that
there it is dude you're [ __ ] on fire
jamie holy [ __ ]
yeah that one number three number three
is bonkers
what is that unless it's a log it could
be a log
so i on my on my second trip back i met
the doctor there was a doctor that lived
in the village close to that river
look at the track and he said he'd seen
it really and he's like not
uh you know i wonder if any like
real legitimate biologists have looked
at those tracks
maybe they could tell you by the way the
footprint like they can kind of tell
whether things are fake or real or not
based on like how
where the weight is distributed like
someone who really understands some
how these animals would would walk i
think it would be really hard to fake
dinosaur footprints right because the
weight it would have to have like it
there the description i just read this
said it wasn't that
big i shouldn't say it's not big but
it's like 30 feet 35 feet
it's pretty big it's like a big big
giant elephant think about how big those
[ __ ] alligators were that we were
just talking about
yeah so it might be a turtle they were
seeing that's what i don't know if what
they actually found
a turtle through here their dicks were
so big
like when we went to the river to bathe
they were like okay they just take their
clothes off and i'm like
oh i'm going to keep my clothes on and
i go they go whoa i go dude i have like
a normal
penis for like i'm proportioned
correctly like your [ __ ] is down to your
knees
and this was back in the city when i got
back to brosserville and they're like
bro you know why our dicks are so big
i'm like why
there's all these naked kids running
around like because we never wear
underwear
and i'm like what like see the girl
whose tits are down to their stomach
never wear bra it's gravity bro
everything just droops
i'm like that's why your dicks are so
big i'm still going to leave my
underwear on like this
takes too much time wait you've never
you've never been africa no
never been after dude i'm begging you
i i know you're into the hunting and the
bow hunting please like
so when i texted you like does it have
to do with anything africa man
hunting in africa you mean so
when i texted you the other day i saw
that the last time i texted you was 2018
i was like dude i'm going to africa i'll
see you when i get back
that's right yeah and um okay this is
the
this is the yes yeah you're telling me
this please very heavy
so there's uh there's hunter-gatherer
tribes in like the arctic
papua new guinea the amazon africa
but very few like they're almost gone
there's very very few people that live
off the land
and i i just
whenever the podcast went off the air
and i and i ghosted i
i just lost my mind i hit my rock bottom
and
very similar pattern of what i always do
when things get rough is i just go to
africa
i go it's a weird thing to be
like rich or be in a country that's rich
or have stuff
and some as an adult someone has to
teach you gratitude like i hear you say
it all the time i'm thankful i'm
thankful
i'm i'm grateful i go but i'm not i have
everything and yet i
[ __ ] complain like crazy i'm like i
need to i need to get the [ __ ] out here
i need to go someplace where
where i can i can learn humility i can
learn to be grateful
so i get to i'm traumatized now by the
congo i didn't even go into my second
combo story when i went with vice that
was even crazier with the [ __ ]
chief try to kill us but um so congo is
the heart of darkness i get why those
books are written i get why people have
these
mind losing experiences out there
because it is one of the
[ __ ] darkest countries i've ever been
so i don't want to go somewhere
different this time
do you know the european settlers they
tried to live in the congo for a while
i met one did you see the houses that
they left behind dude
when i got to this bantu village and uh
chuck his name was chuck chuck if you're
listening i know it's 20 years ago
long blonde hair from oregon peace corps
guy
he got malaria while we were there and
he goes
please contact francois and i go who the
[ __ ] is francois
and he goes he's he's in the jungle and
this is this isn't in the congo village
is the bontu village
and he goes you go down this tree and
you go so it's he's deep in the
in the but this is still near a village
it's not you know
so we go into the in the jungle and
there's like a giant
victorian french like european house in
the middle of the [ __ ] jungle
and i'm like how did this happen and
he's like so we go in there
and uh francois is just like
like uh some [ __ ] weird french dude
that just
said i'm gonna stay here he had like 12
bantu wives there's all these like half
black half white babies crawling around
and he has a ham radio and he's like
what's going on i'm like chuck
is [ __ ] dying can he said to come
contact you he's like okay i'll contact
the
aircraft carrier and they'll send a
chopper in for him
i was like oh [ __ ] but yeah that's
that's the one time i saw a french
victorian i don't even know how to
describe the architecture it was like a
beautiful french home
in the middle of the [ __ ] congo
jungle yeah there was a website
dedicated to
uh those people that tried to do that
and it just
detailed how it all went terrible for
them the jungle just over
came the house like you can't keep the
jungle back it's too powerful there's
too much there
the jungle everything grows so quickly
it's just [ __ ]
i mean you'd have grass popping out
through the middle of your floorboards
and [ __ ] and
trees trying to grow through the side of
your sewage system
like they're just it's just too much
it's wild when my life when you just
said too much like
i just thought right now every time in
my my i hit a rock bottom and my life
gets too much
i go back to africa so when someone says
go back to where you come from maybe
it's africa well we all do
right we all do so i look at tanzania on
the map
and it's pretty close to the congo and
i'm like [ __ ] am i ready for that
and i heard from so many people how nice
the tanzanians saw
i went life-changing experience
i meet i meet the hodza who you gotta
understand this is how
humans have been living for two million
years and the odds have been in this
area for 50 000 years
and and uh
i go same thing they're like who are you
know are you tourists i go
can i just like live with you guys for a
little bit they're like they're they're
so nice
they're so welcoming they don't even um
they don't even have like the words for
like violence and hate and
you know they're very present
and um i go i i i my
my life is falling apart like i i'm
i'm mentally ill i'm bipolar i'm manic
depressive i'm addicted to [ __ ]
everything my disease is a disease of
more i need more
there's a bottomless pit i can never
feel i just need to like
run away that's that's my action my my
action response to everything
my whole life is to run away so i'm in
africa no one's gonna [ __ ] find me
here
and i'm living with this tribe the hodza
and they go
so i say living but it's not really
living because they're living in a cave
they're hunting they're gathering
i stayed there for a week doing the fake
living i am in a tent
i have a gen like these guys are
carrying all this [ __ ] for me my water
like truckloads of water and
in that time i saw in one week how much
trash i live
leave behind like i don't see it here
because it goes in the bin the trash man
comes
in one week these guys leave zero carbon
footprint
they come to a place they're nomadic
they set up the shop they hunt they live
and then they go to the next place
i left a mountain of bottles
toilet paper clif bar wrapper you know
that's what i was eating there
and i go this is sad one human being
left a mountain
of trash and i go what do we do and
they're like we burn it we burned trash
and i was like whoa
environment and uh
they go do you wanna do you wanna really
live with us because one week
in any kind of situation like that is
it's just
withdrawal right i mean i mean internet
withdrawal phone withdrawal
friend like just comforts of of normal
like western society and i go [ __ ] it
[ __ ] the tent the general i'm gonna live
with you guys i'm just gonna [ __ ]
you know so i'm in my [ __ ] underwear
and i'm living on top of a rock in this
cave and the oldest guy in the village
is you know when he starts talking it's
like uh i'm in like lion king or he's
like when i was young and all
you know i have a translator with me
he's translating
to swahili to english he's like
elephants lions hippos
like everywhere and like it was like a
buffet
we just wake up we could kill anything
and in my lifetime
that has been gone it's gone it's like
there's very few animals left to hunt
and the ones that are
like they're endangered you can't kill
them
so life there is very very hard
and they go you want to hunt with us and
i'm like
dude look at my body do i look like
and um there was like a catholic uh
priest that set up a mission in that
area
and he's been i met him he's been trying
to convert the hadza to
catholicism for 20 years and he's like
they use the
the bible pages to smoke weed
so what do they hunt with bow and arrow
like
homemade bow and arrow homemade bow and
arrow like like just
they they take this wood and they spent
all day making the arrows
yup they use their teeth yeah i'll show
you how they did i learned how to
make it and then i they use their teeth
to
i think i know that guy
that might be rasuli um and then they
um there's a plant that they
um they harvest and they they do all the
stuff to it and then that's the poison
that they put on the tip of the arrow
and these guys yep there it is
how crazy it is to think that this is
how people hunted
dude i lived the longest time dude i
lived in a state of the art i lived like
this for [ __ ] months man it was like
so you did this as well dude so
first first day of the hunt they're like
did they teach you how to shoot a bow
first
dude my bow shooting is so off and um
yeah so we practiced had you had shot a
bow in the past i've never shot a bow in
in my life there's one of these one of
these guys
see it it almost looks like a toy like
you think it wouldn't work
there's one guy in the village shawnee
that's so strong
that he could shoot the arrow through
the [ __ ] kudu
and i was like you're [ __ ] super back
muscles
oh my god they're [ __ ] ripped dude my
god that guy is jacked they're ripped
so they have really these are very
strong bones so
pulling them back is probably tremendous
like back muscle
everyone knows how to hunt the kids know
how to hunt what are they using for the
feathers at the end of i know that i
know
i think it's the one that's the which
guy
no yeah that guy yup
i stayed with that guy whoa really yeah
he's older now
see the cuts on his face yeah i have
that they cut my face
yeah yeah i asked them too because i
like paint
for real but but look at that guy
doesn't where's your cut it's almost
gone now this was a
damn dude but don't don't they look like
supermodels
like they're like really powerful
cosmetics yeah i'm like just
and also you got to think of the amount
of effort they're it's like they're
doing crossfit classes every day
right i mean think about just getting by
as a hunter-gatherer with a crazy bow
that you have to pull back and you're
running through the woods all the time
like
you have to be fit it's it's
unbelievable
then what a crazy way to live yeah look
at that
i mean walking in for the feathers for
the fletchings do you know
dude these [ __ ] are so in tune
with nature that they'll go they'll make
a bird sound
and they're talking to the bird and the
bird will show you where the honey is
what like and then there's a pack of 50
dogs following us
and the dogs aren't pets they're hunting
tools
right so the dogs are the first line of
defense they sniff it out
and i'm like this is this is mental
right it's like oh like
i'm on a [ __ ] insane experience right
now never did i thought i would just
wait why why am i going home so if i
walk with one of the kids
amazing it's a clicking language it's
like like that kind of language
did you learn any of it tiny bit and i
did of course i did a podcast where i
speak
imagine if they take that out of context
it turns out you're saying some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
i try you gotta be careful right if
you're making up a language like you
might accidentally hit on some real [ __ ]
there
i tried i tried just say one or two
forbidden words
so if i walk with one of the kids and
it's like him giving me a tour of his
house like oh come to joe's warehouse
and he's showing me
right he's like grabbing a snake biting
his head off
he's like you want some thing climbing a
tree
he just grabbed a snake and just he
takes out his slingshot
the rock a pebble this big bam hits a
[ __ ] bush baby out of the tree
breaks his leg breaks his legs puts it
here it's like snack for later
everything is talking they're it's like
it looks like they're just goofing off
and playing but they're
they have like must they have um
some uh what do you call it microbes and
gut biome kind of things in their
stomach that no one else on the planet
has
so the translator is explaining to me
canadian
uh science like scientists come and
literally steal their [ __ ]
they find them and they steal their [ __ ]
and i'm like they're actual poop they're
actual people to get their bio
because there's biomes in there that
don't exist anywhere secret to a
healthier
dude they might have hidden
google steal african [ __ ] i bet you
it'll come up see look there it is
so this [ __ ] see the bees on his [ __ ]
head they're lighting them up and he's
eating the honey and it does
nothing to him really so we go climb hey
come on climb the tree
guy sticks his [ __ ] hand in the tree
scoops that out
starts eating it like it's a [ __ ]
hamburger bees and i'm like bro i'm cool
no no no come on come on like we've been
there's a kid doing this right that
kid's
i go in one sting my [ __ ] hand
inflates to like a mickey mouse
like it it's j i'm like you've been
getting stung
since you were a kid so you're like
immune to it
and they're just doesn't bother them it
doesn't bother them they're they're fine
with it and their body has also gotten
immune to it
right that's crazy they're biting that
honeycomb like it's a snack
and all those bees were on his head his
hands
and the thing you never see in all the
national geographics and all the nature
documentaries
is that it's always serious and here's
the
hadzo warrior and here's you know
whatever nate these guys
crack you know they're like do you want
to do you want to come with us tomorrow
like none of your eating clif bars and
hanging back like you want
i'm like yeah i'm in okay we leave at
first you know the second
how are they saying this all to you i
have the translator with me okay okay
he he like works with them in the you
know
it's like worst case scenario when they
they don't do food
this is the sad part they do the fake
show for the tourists
like the tourists come in usually
european and then they put on the fake
it's not fake it's real but they dress
up and do like dances and stuff and they
give them money
um so i wake up at you know 5 5
30. first noise
and then laughter i'm like are these
[ __ ] doing fart jokes at five in the
morning
and that's the thing that people don't
realize is
when you don't have tv internet
entertainment and you're just with your
family and your homies all day
you're bored as [ __ ] so they joke
morning till night like
i don't know what they're saying
laughter laughter someone cuts a fart
joke and i'm like all right let's go so
you saw the pictures they're ripped back
muscles six packs the kids have six
packs
i was very out of shape i'm still out of
shape but i was the most out of shape
and think about waking up at 5 30 in the
morning
and the thing that's the the final
animal that's like kind of left
is baboons they call they almost call
them in in
that part of africa like the baboon men
because that's what they eat
tastes horrible to me baboons look human
so we're in a cave men sleeping on the
top
ben women on the bottom wait wake up
there's another cave
and you see oh there's people on that
cave no they're baboons
and they're pointing at us they're
pointing they're like look
they're coming so i'm like this [ __ ] is
crazy we're hunting baboons
like there's tons of meat on them we're
gonna it's enough to feed our family
think about like running again
i was pretty fast in high school i could
do the 50 pretty quick
i can't run at top speed for hours and
and i got these i'm drinking water
and in this environment it's an
advantage to have black skin because
it's cooling
these guys aren't sweating i'm like
what's going on we've been running for
five hours you guys aren't sweating
what the [ __ ] and they don't get tired
and then they'll just start digging a
hole and drink like
like a handful of brown water and that's
enough for them
and i'm like dude what the [ __ ] like i
and they're telling the translator this
[ __ ] looks like he's never
caught anything in his life
and he's like he hasn't and to me i'm an
alien
right they go he he gets his food from
supermarkets
what's that they hunt the food
for him they cut it up and package it
and sell it like
they don't believe it right the [ __ ] i
tell them they're like hey you guys
you look like a [ __ ] supermodel can i
bring you to america and do a fashion
thing and get you guys paid and
why would we want to go to america well
tell me what you know about america
isn't that the place where people jump
off
buildings to kill themselves like that
concept is so foreign
that when someone explained suicide to
them i was like oh my god they don't
and in in the time that i'm there like i
said that first week is withdrawal i'm
like [ __ ] where's my phone
and then all of it goes away right i'm
not thinking about
any of my addictions i'm not thinking
about
like i feel peace i'm not i'm not
miserable my depression goes away
and i go morning till night
you wake up you hunt for food you get
home
celebration everyone's happy that the
men brought the food back the women
you know gathered the berries we have a
big dinner celebration because every
meal you got to be grateful for
dance party by the fire and you're out a
couple fart jokes and you're out
repeat the next day there's no time to
be like bored and
sad and upset and been worried about
some [ __ ]
and so i'm trying to keep up with these
guys you know they're they're running at
top speed like
say this is um say these are the baboons
on top of the they're doing a perimeter
they're doing them and okay we're going
to come up all the sides and the
and the and the dogs are on the
forefront right they're running faster
there's a guy named he's got some dreads
he's uh he's the
the villain the tribe we pothead
he's got the bible he's rolling joints
for everyone
he's about 50 feet behind you know he's
running at like a
he's not doing this he's like he's got
i'm maybe like two 300 feet behind this
guy
so they're they're trying to like you
know come on so he's running and rolling
joints he's running rolling joints
and and have you done any running before
this
not really man i'm a sprinter i i don't
i can't i don't have all the time
you're doing this for hours oh my god i
almost blacked out how many miles you
think you were running
dude because they're like going back and
forth we're like
i'm like dude i'm just gonna chill here
they just run everywhere run everywhere
just running and you know they don't
some of them have shoes like they make
homemade shoes but some of them don't so
it's just barefoot and i'm
they're run it's the it's the dry bush
right so there's like
plants that have like thorns and like it
looks like this on them just like that
white scratch to me i'm getting cut open
i'm like bleeding everywhere ah
their skin's tough and they're just
[ __ ] they're just clowning
they're clowning me they're like bro how
did you
ever survive and i'm like i'm like come
on come on guys
i put a gopro on the dog so i go back
and i watch it
the baboon is like a human like it's
talking get the [ __ ] away from me
the [ __ ] away the baboon's running the
dog
[ __ ] you they hunt him with dogs he gets
hit
right here he's bleeding so he's leaving
a trail of blood that [ __ ] hypes up
the tribe let's go
we got him he's hit the dog gets his
nutsack rips his [ __ ] dick off
i'm running the guy holds up his nuts
he's like look we got the nuts and i'm
like why are you showing me that he's
like he's
we're getting close they finally [ __ ]
hit the guy like sort of
here and and they're saying the guy too
you're not just saying the baboon you're
saying it hit the guy
it looks human man god it does right it
looks
real close he backs into a tree like a
dog human though yeah
and and all the dogs the dogs are dope i
love these dogs so much
they're all hunting dogs so they all
have scars and
[ __ ] tails missing like because the
baboons have fangs
yeah they pick the dogs up and they rip
a chunk off oh my god
and these dogs are so hardcore that
there's a dog that had one leg missing
there's a dog that you could see his
ribs and they're still down to hunt
oh my god like they're in the back with
me but they're still like i i want to
show value
that you know because i i talked i
interviewed each person in the tribe
and i said what is the happiest day of
your life
and they all had the same answer the day
that i hunted the biggest animal and i
got to feed everyone and i was the hero
and
so i'm all baboons for how long how long
have they been
only hunting baboons i mean it's been
for a few years now
i mean they'll hunt anything they'll
kill anything right and they'll there's
nothing left but baboons just recently
it's getting to just that and even even
then because this day
that that day that i was on my first
hunt because there was many days we
hunted where we didn't catch anything
and that's like super downer for them
but this is my first hunt i had the
gopro the guy shot
he backs into a tree like his last stand
and the dogs just
start ripping his guts out and start
[ __ ]
you know and i'm watching this and he's
like and it's like he's going
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and he's just like
he's like
picking dogs up throwing them oh my god
and then just come up and they go
right in his chest he's dead
this is all on gopro i wasn't even close
i was like
i was like wait up guys [ __ ]
they tie the the foot and the leg and
they make a backpack
that's how they carry it so they caught
four that day so they bring it back to
the village
i i don't know if you saw in that
picture i brought my top ramen with me
so i was like
they don't waste a part of this thing
the person that killed it gets to eat
the dick in the balls
they eat the head they eat the brains
they turn the fur into like jackets
and um they just they eat the brains
dude so at night i thought
i thought dinner time was over but think
about it how much protein and nutrition
is in the brain right
and it's the final thing right they stew
the head that's in that pot
and so the brain gets cooked and then
it's like a delicacy at the end they
like tap a hole in
and it's you know they have black skin
like i remember like
it was fire it was in the cave it's
nighttime
and i hear i just hear eating and i turn
my
my flashlight on and i see like the
whole tribe
just chowing the brains at the end
they're like this is our favorite part
and they save it for the end yeah and
they're just like and then so it's all
those white brains like streaked on
their face and i'm like
yo you want to get in on this give me
some of that brain
so i had some brain did you really i ate
everything i mean
it's there it is oh my god doesn't that
look like a person
that's so intense so once the fur is not
on the screen
no yeah good once
well let me just say this if that's how
hardcore this picture is right
you can find it you can find it easily
look for like like you want to talk up
this is life or death
this is you know what this is i
understand so when when
but i'm saying um it is intense and
there is a thing about primate brains
right um prions prion diseases that you
get uh
they find them in cannibals there's
something about eating a human
smoking weed humans eating human brains
oh so they did get a bird there
yeah so sometimes they get birds too so
i am
but they're eating mostly baboons i eat
i tasted it i wasn't eating it i'm like
i have a million clif bars in my
backpack i know
that is so intense there's the dogs
seeing that guy carry a baboon on his
back like the way you're describing is
so intense
they got a some sort of an antelope or
something there and then they're
drinking out of that water
but they're smoking weed with the bible
dude look at this [ __ ] guy
um so i'm i i pass out there's nothing
left in the gas tank i pass out and the
next day i'm like okay
like like i'm becoming a man they're
like did you eat
the actual baboon meat as well i ate the
baboon meat it's
not for me it's and i eat everything
what it tastes like
i've never eaten a human but i'm
imagining that's what a human would
taste like
it was just i don't know gamey
that's the only it's it was just it was
strong
but um well you got to think of the
physical strength of those animals
to how tough their meat must be and all
the testosterone and everything is being
released
it didn't taste good but they loved it
they love the
they're happy you know steve vanello no
stephen nell is the host of uh the tv
show meat eater and he went to um
i'm trying to remember where it was
somewhere in south america and they they
ate monkeys there
and he had some of it and he said it was
uh it's like they smoke it
and then they cook it in like a stew and
it's like smoked turkey they did that to
the head
but there he is there's um so they're
eating this monkey
in uh they're chewing on it like that's
that's intense man bolivia that is
[ __ ] intense like seeing someone
chewing on a monkey leg
is intense you know yeah there's just
something about it where it's like
that's our cousins that's next level i
mean there's something about it it's
like
this is this is life life or death it's
crazy how much we
but we think that way about mammals in
general because if you get to deer
like people are way sadder when they see
a dead deer then they see a dead fish
there's something about like mammals
right right like we don't give a
[ __ ] about a dead turtle when they throw
that thing on the fire
and you see all the fur burn off and oh
he's like in the christ pose
it looks like human so the next day i'm
like
all right i'm i'm getting my endurance
up and they're like we think you're more
of a gatherer
why don't you hang back today like
because they were like humoring me right
i was like okay okay and i brought all
my art supplies with me
and the kids are like they use the
beeswax
and they make little sculptures and they
take little you know
i'm like these kids are awesome so i
fell in love with the kids i'm like i'll
adopt all of you i'll bring they're like
we have
parents i was like all right
so i brought all these art supplies with
me i got markers i got watercolor
and you know there it's we're in the
desert it's all brown so i mean not the
desert we're in the bush everything's
brown and so i got all these bright
blues and reds and
the kids went nuts like when you give
kids art supplies like and i'm just
watching them like this is
[ __ ] amazing and the day just went by
i just gave art lessons and
like to someone who's never seen art
supplies that must be [ __ ] insane and
i'm yeah and i'm asking them like what
you know and they're drawing like the
hun they're drawing because they've
never seen tv
they've never they don't have any of the
visual like stuff that we grew up on so
everything is pure from that perspective
and in my head i'm like i cannot wait
to get home and show this to people and
maybe we can do prints and books and
sell it and help you guys and
they go okay they show you know everyone
comes back from the hunt they show
and they go we're on top of this this
cliff the cave and they just throw it
hey
what the [ __ ] you guys doing man i was
gonna you know in my head it's like
come home frame it you know there's a
memory of my time there
they're like oh nomadic you don't guys
we were present we created it we lived
it we enjoyed it
bye bye like what am i gonna walk around
with the [ __ ]
canvas and paper and i was like damn
dude this [ __ ] is
these people are next level and so
that's a different world
well that's why i'm saying like i was
like man
now i got this experience i feel good
i'm going to go home and i'm like
why am i going to go home like i'm
[ __ ] falling in love with these
people
they're showing me how [ __ ] up i am
and like what i
and so i just stayed there i just stayed
there about how long
stayed there for a few months i bought a
huge piece of land i work with um if
anyone
that's listening right now is interested
it's uh hadza h-a-d-z-a
dot org and you can you can if you want
to like sponsor a kid or you want to see
how they live and because it's this is
it this is the end for them
like it might already be the end like i
don't know if anyone listening has
tanzania contacts
like this way of life is pretty much
over like
in there's less than a thousand hadza
left
yeah these are the guys i stayed with
they're [ __ ] amazing
um and and uh
dude will you come yes what do you go to
africa is that what you're saying yeah
i thought you meant come to like the
movie premiere
um dude please please i
your your daughters your wife will
[ __ ] love it like you don't
and here's the thing we could set it up
where you don't have to like i gave you
like the [ __ ] heart malaria tour
yeah you take malaria pills you're not
going to get malaria
and you can't do that for kids though
you could malaria medication
so i meant good i met a spanish german
couple there that has like a
nice kind of bed and breakfast kind of
thing like not in
the that area but a little bit away and
the guy
raises his kid like at nice private
schools in germany
and then in on the summer times he comes
and the kids in their underwear run
around and they hunt with the
tribe and i'm like this is life changing
your [ __ ] kids look at these kids
yeah look at how look at they're all
smiling having like the [ __ ] time of
their life
look at the dogs look at the dog
yeah hodza.org how many baboons do you
think you ate while you were there
i'm telling i'm being honest with you i
just it a little bit and then i go into
my
my my little cubby hole and eat my clif
bars
so you only ate their meals look at that
i painted
the oh my god them biting a chunk off
the baboon's head
oh jesus dude
i mean it's it's it's crazy to think
that
it's like the cure to like future
medicines and [ __ ] might be in these
guys as [ __ ]
and then they're gonna be crazy dude
it's [ __ ] insane like
we met those scientists that are
collecting that data out there
um [ __ ] i can't remember her name well
obviously neither one of us is a
biologist but if you think about it
if you're living like in a completely
uh natural way in the middle of
i mean what a crazy biosphere
there's so much life there yeah there's
so much
so much life there that you gotta
imagine there's so much bacteria life
too right
and if you survived to 2020 like your
ancestors got you to 2020 living like
that like you have to be robust
so all those people that do live there
they're probably just a superior version
any one of those guys could have been a
supermodel because when they take their
shirt off they're [ __ ]
ripped and the guy shawny that i said
when he hits a a kudu like the big with
the arrow it goes all the way through
and i'm like the other one other guys in
the tribe when they hit it it hits the
animals they're [ __ ] shrek dude they
look like those guys in the center
that's insane they're [ __ ] shredded
they look like jiu jitsu dude they're
[ __ ] amazing they do
those guys well you gotta think man i
mean the the amount of physical activity
and exercise
but probably their endurance is like
never waning
right running doing it and i'm sitting
there and i'm i'm thinking with my
western brain dude if i take you back
you guys are going to be the toast of
the town fashion models if
if someone trains your bose thing like
you could be in the olympics or maybe
you could be a [ __ ]
baseball player or well how about
runners from there runners from parts
there's one part of africa in particular
that's responsible for a tremendous
amount of long-distance runners
and they had a um radio lab podcast
about it and they said that
it was because of their ability to
endure pain that they had a ritual when
they were a coming-of-age ritual
where they would uh circumcise the men
like with a dull knife and have them
crawl
naked through like thorns like they did
they did some
hard core [ __ ] to these guys when they
were young
to get them to just be able to endure
pain in a way that most people just
incapable of they've developed a
tolerance to pain because
some of the rituals the the episode is
called cut and run
it's really crazy because this guy talks
about it but he also says
because he had gone through it himself
and he also said he doesn't want to do
it
to his son he wouldn't want his son to
do that it's like it's you don't have to
do it it's too hard
but that it makes sense man it does make
sense it just makes total sense just
because i think i look i'm not a long
distance runner but those people that
are they say it's all about your mind
right it's all about being able to
endure the pain right and some people
can and some people can't and
if you're a person who's grown up
dealing with pain it's a part of your
culture
you know you got to be hard as [ __ ] to
make it in the congo dude
hard as [ __ ] to make it in tanzania you
got to be hard as [ __ ]
those people like you got to think of
all of those
different obstacles their ancestors have
overcome
to get them to 2020 living a nomadic
life
in the jungle holy [ __ ] man i mean you
can't be lazy you can't be slow
you can't be stupid you you have to be
able and you're taught to be
able to maneuver in that world from the
time you're a baby
joe you can't just read about it you've
got to live it what
is the fear like that you might get
malaria or something i'm really high
i took a bunch of uh hits of that blunt
during this podcast you too jamie you
[ __ ]
you're coming too jamie's not leaving
this apartment you're crazy i'm gonna
i'll make it so it's the most the best
we'll talk for your family
we'll talk about it after the show i'm
going to keep because dude like
i love it when people bugged me about
things i say no to but please keep going
i thought you like bow hunting man i'm
not going over there
if i did that i would only go over there
let's like you know
just observe come to observe if i did if
i went to hunt over there i would do it
because that's what i wanted to live off
of i wanted to eat it
like you can't i don't think you bring
it back no no we didn't donate we were
tribes
we would eat it yeah trust me we would
eat it it would get eaten everything
there gets eaten
yeah i talked to a dude once who uh shot
an elephant over there i was like
whoa like why and then he said well
first of all the reason why they do it
in the first place is because
some of these elephants will make their
way into towns and start eating in the
village and eating all their crops
and so they want someone to come and
shoot it and i'm like oh man
like that's a crazy argument like
there's there's certain animals that i
feel
way worse when they die and elephants
there's something about elephants
elephants are cute
that's it's they're not just cute man
they're dinosaurs
there's something majestic about yeah
they're [ __ ] amazing they could crush
you and they they're
genuinely pretty cool they're so cool
strangers
like regular tourists are allowed to
climb on them in thailand and ride them
through the jungle
you ever meet michael jackson the uh the
singer yeah
no so i got to meet him close to
before he died and i got to go to
neverland ranch whoa
the the mismanagement of the animals
there
is like the they were already gone by
the time i got there but where he used
to keep the elephants
the bars are like this thick and the
elephants were so
like depressed and and you know just
from
like they didn't have an actual
zookeeper that knew how to handle him so
they would just keep him locked up and
like not
the elephants would [ __ ] head bang
the bars these bars are like this thick
and they'd be bent like this
oh my god i'm like man these [ __ ]
things
are dinosaurs they're all so intelligent
yeah they're really smart they're smart
yeah they're smart they have feelings
they feel things
like have you ever seen that they taught
them to paint
yeah i've seen that that's awesome how
crazy is that
i mean that thing is painting itself i
love that here's my question
do you think they taught it we we
actually talked about this jamie didn't
we
like do you think they actually taught
him to make that shape
or do you think they taught him to paint
himself
right like if you if you could show an
elephant like this is the shape i want
you to make
and it's the shape of an of an elephant
if you drew it for him
and you said recreate that i give you
fruit he recreates that you give him
fruit right that's a little different
than if he looks at you and starts
drawing an image of you because that's
we were led to believe that the elephant
was thinking of itself
and drawing what an elephant looks like
right it's just a slightly less
impressive thing that it might just be
emotion that it's taught to make
but the way you look at it like you go
no it's too good
it's too good like the elephant has a
little talent
like it's a like i would buy an elephant
painting
you should just to know that an elephant
did it but i don't want the elephants to
have to be
forced to work right right right you
want the elephant to want to yeah
paint paint it i'm glad the elephant
just leave these paints here
and if you want to do it yes like
exactly like if
the elephant was living a chill life i
went to a
elephant rescue place in thailand a
couple years back and um
they rescued these elephants and
released them back into the wild
successfully wow they've done it with
several i think they said
seven at the time that i was there but
they basically take elephants from like
a circus or a zoo
and they rehabilitate them and they they
they have them out here there's like
piles of sugar cane
you could feed him sugarcane wow and
this thing is like
this big it's head's this big and i'm
i'm petting it and i'm just feeding it
sugarcane but they're so
gentle right that strangers like me i
just met him
right but if you wanted to you could do
just
you just you're a beer can man you just
stomp you
[ __ ] yeah pile drive you he do
whatever he wants to
he's so big and then when you you
feed them and you wash them and you hang
out with them and then they'll let you
ride them
like you developed like a little bond
with them
it's interesting man because like you
you're hanging out with this elephant
and you're feeding them
and he goes to you to try to eat and
then you petting them and then you could
wash them and
he's enjoying it he's enjoying that
you're doing this and then
then after all that then you ride them i
don't like the riding part
if i had to do it all over again i'd be
like i'm good i'll meet you guys at the
end i don't want to worry
i don't want to ride them but i get that
it's but it's fascinating
and they're they don't give a [ __ ] like
you weigh nothing you you're a baseball
hat to them
what's the uh prehistoric what's the
mastodon
is that the the snuffaloffice guy from
oh wells wooly mammoth there's two
different ones
yeah so when you're when you're in the
presence of something so majestic you're
like
you can believe yeah there's a dinosaur
oh 100
well it would be a dinosaur if it didn't
exist right like if an elephant didn't
exist and someone talked about it giant
right giant white teeth that come up up
into the sky
it's enormous it's as big as a house
what
i love the babies they're so cute yeah
people who if you didn't know what an
elephant was and someone was describing
it didn't exist and someone's describing
it to you
right they said it was off in the jungle
somewhere you'd be like what right
what is it a leftover dinosaur
you know we were trying to figure out
the other day we forgot to check how
old are crocodiles we were saying that
crocodiles are dinosaurs but the
dinosaurs supposedly were killed off 65
million years ago right
are crocodiles something that actually
survived
before them how old does this say they
are 200 million years old holy [ __ ]
those dirty [ __ ] made it
through the asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs
those are those are dinosaurs they are
prehistoric yeah if they're if it's 200
million years ago
i mean of course they're dinosaurs of
course they are right
jamie are there uh crocodiles that paint
i was looking up so that there's one the
one elephant that that way you know the
viral video of it
it's got it's painting in really good
detail yeah
but right there's there's oh wow that
has no way
lots of elephant this is like the the
conservation elephant art.com
so these things are way different okay
it's like the picasso
is there some cheating going on i mean
that's what i'm saying right
i was saying maybe he's the michael
jordan of uh elephant painters but there
was one or two i was like digging
through here that was painting like
flowers with
stems and petals and leaves the rest of
this is just like
you should see the video play dave the
video because the video is interesting
so the painting elephant the uh look
he's carrying his supplies
up and look it does the whole outline
itself like no one's guiding it
great composition
look at that good stuff you're not
seeing
you're just seeing the trunk is there
someone behind it with a stick
tape to it like sort of moving it i
don't think so i think back here it does
show you
oh okay all right it's zoomed out yeah i
don't think so
i think it's got skills man control like
look it knows how to outline the ear
that makes me feel like it's almost been
classically trained though
like look how thick the line is of the
ear and then it
sort of tapers off speaking of painting
or
are you painting at all no why don't you
paint man
i never paint i've draw i used to draw a
lot i know that i didn't
i never i've never really gotten into
painting not that i i don't think it's
awesome i just
look i come to your place you have these
[ __ ] paintings everywhere
yeah i've seen your tattoos that you
that you like to draw you like to draw
werewolves
you talk all day yeah don't you want to
do something where you don't have to
talk and it's
still expressing yourself and you like
art i do sometimes i still scribble i i
draw things sometimes
but mostly um my days are busy
because this is like the best way to
like archery i like archery for calming
down
okay because that just makes me [ __ ]
just focus on a target
and i just really it's a very zen thing
to do i'm gonna send some art supplies
to texas you just leave them there okay
dude it's like the elephant okay i'm not
gonna force you to do it okay they're
just there and if you want to
then you do it okay i do love drawing
still
to this day but i've really never i've
been drawing a lot lately
but i'm i recognize my limitations
because whatever particular mental
mental health problems that i have
i get obsessed with things and i i don't
have the time to get obsessed with
painting
oh i see so if i if i draw like i i've
been drawing since i was a kid it's not
like a new thing
new things are dangerous to me you sound
like me now
it's true well that's why i i walked
away from
from podcasting i just i
i go i know what this means to me i know
what kind of person i
am like i'm all in like this is like
i'll never paint again like this is
going to take over my life
and then i remember i went on the stern
show
same thing like five six years ago and i
i was like i don't even know what i said
i was completely like
out of my mind and scott rudin's
assistant heard it the hollywood
producer guy
and he heard the show send the tape to
scott rudin i got a call from scott
rudin he's like
i need to turn your life into a
television show it's like it's
it's too un like it's unbelievable like
it's like i've never heard that like
you're in the congo you're in jail
you're this like we gotta turn this into
a show
so i'm 38
i don't know something like that like
[ __ ] i made it i'm gonna be famous i'm
gonna be on tv
and i i was like man i got a [ __ ]
podcast that's gonna be huge
i'm gonna be on tv i'm doing the [ __ ]
uh
news for vice we just got an emmy i'm a
painter
i i got every [ __ ] thing i do turns
to gold i'm the best like i'm
i'm uh multitasking i can do it all
and at the time is when i got introduced
to
bourdain and and and scott and scott had
this deal with hbo
he's like what kind of show you want i'm
like i love kirby enthusiasm i like
eastbound and down
i like stupid irreverent comedy i'm like
make me look like [ __ ] make me the heel
just [ __ ] clown on me
make every episode just whatever story i
tell you
do the worst worst [ __ ] version of it
and they're like okay i get the
hollywood lawyers and the [ __ ] thing
and i'm like mom i'm gonna be on tv
and i'm having lunch at chateau marmont
i just met bourdain
and chateau marmont's like the hipster
hollywood
thing where even celebrities get left
alone not bourdain
in one lunch and you must get this all
the time now
i sorry i see you guys are having lunch
i just got to tell you
what you mean to me and he's gracious
every time thank you thank you
can i get a picture can you sign my book
oh can i get another picture for you
know
lunch is interrupted 20 30 40 i don't
know every every five minutes someone's
coming to the table oh i know
and i go is this how do you get milk
how do you he's like he's like
everything just takes longer dave
just takes longer now and i'm like wait
let me let me let me do a quick scan of
my life right now
i get lots of women i got i i can eat at
any restaurant and and
i have no wants or desires everything's
handled
and i have just the amount of little bit
of fame for my art where like
no one's bothering me when i walk down
the street once in a while
i'm at a supermarket and someone's like
dvd i say and that's it
i have it why am i so i i walked away
from that deal
and at the same time i've been flirting
with it
bourdain he wasn't going to do it
forever and he started grooming me
roy choi david chang to kind of take
over for him he's like you're
you've had it wasn't like a huge step
for me because i've already been doing
that and i think that's how we connected
he's like
you know i have thumbs up which is a
travel show where i [ __ ] with people and
i go
meet people over the planet you have
yours millions of people watch your show
10 people watch your show but
um you can do it with like an art twist
you know
and i sat there and i was like [ __ ] bro
i don't know if i want your life
i don't know if i want this you know i
had that moment of clarity and all the
chaos of
i need another thing in my life to show
people
that the gambling wasn't a fluke the art
wasn't a fluke that
that i'm not just lucky that i'm
talented that i am enough
and the anger is like oh i'm going to be
on [ __ ] tv now i'm going to [ __ ]
kill it
and i was like my life's pretty dope
right now i don't know
and dope like on the surface like
underneath you know i'm just
a cauldron of suffering but i said i
think i'm not gonna i'm not gonna take
this one and uh scott if you're out
there i'm sorry like
we we walked away from that project and
then um
that's interesting just because you saw
the
what the repercussions of the fame part
well it's isn't it bill murray quote i
want to be rich and famous and he goes
why don't you just try rich first and
see if you want to add the famous to it
or something like that
it's like you deal with that now right
yeah i mean people just some people see
what what other people have and they
wish it was them
like i remember being a comic in the
beginning the early days
um when i was you know just coming up
and
opening for people i remember seeing
people that would be excited to see a
comedian i'd be like wow
that's [ __ ] crazy like the person
this person i know people want to meet
him
right they want to see him like man why
what do i have to do
like there's a part of you at 21 years
old right like what the [ __ ] do i have
to do
to to be like that guy so what is your
life like now
with like the last time i saw you i mean
you've been famous since i've known you
but it's
exploded since then can you go to the
restaurant can you go to
restaurants most people are nice most
people are friendly so how do you deal
with the
great joe rogan experience changed my
life like say what's up what's up what's
up nice to meet you just keep walking
moving nice to meet you i gotta get out
of here
but most people are cool they want they
just want to say hi
hi is fine man nothing wrong i love it
i'm happy i
i love that people enjoy it but it's a
mind [ __ ] and you got to be careful
it is a mind [ __ ] mind [ __ ] is it's a
like just meeting people that know you
and you don't know them
that's not a normal state for human
beings it's weird
no it's not you know so someone said it
best once and i
took this on early on that like you meet
like you have to have a like reset
like the the real problem like sometimes
people get upset and they meet too many
people
but i'm like we gotta have a reset like
every person is a new person like this
is the first time you ever
did they don't it's not their fault you
met three people in a row on your way to
the bathroom
this is still the first time they're
meeting you but you could get stuck in a
spot too though
right you go to a bar where everybody's
a little drunk and then you're mobbed
and then
people want to take pictures and hug you
and do you think that's going to be
more or less in texas i don't know man
i think if i thought like that i would
never do anything
you'd never take any chances never do
anything different
i'm jealous man i think it's i think i
need to get the [ __ ] out of la man i was
born and raised here i'm angelino
i think for everybody we're all
realizing because this pandemic that
there's uh
pros and cons to cities but when [ __ ]
gets ugly
there's a lot of cons there's a lot of
cons to
being overcrowded right and there's a
lot of
i mean there's also a little bit of a
problem with the just the sheer amount
of people
if the virus is spreading right because
there's so many of us we're in the hot
spot we're in the middle of it right now
yeah
and there's so many of us you know do
you see the herman cain thing
no herman cain the guy who ran for
president he uh just died of coronavirus
and this is after he had went to a one
of them trump rallies
um one of his campaign rallies with no
mask on
and then it was i think he was admitted
to the hospital ten days after that
right is that what it was
it's a rough way to go man do it this
shit's crazy it's crazy
you know what it's like dude it's like
it's like 10 different diseases
like you talk to one person it seems
like no big deal the other person tells
you they're still not well four months
later they've got neurological diseases
one person's mom beat it in a day the
other person
do you remember um in the 80s when
aids like yeah like people didn't
understand it yet did you speak in a's i
have to pee so bad
i drank so much water before this so
let's pause this is not speaking of aids
okay you were making an aids joke i was
i just have to pee
we'll be right back ladies and gentlemen
i just drank too much water my apologies
no worries
welcome to real talk with david cho i
didn't i didn't uh
um we'll get back to eights but i didn't
i didn't i didn't dye my hair
um because i'm uh trying to like
empathize with gingers or whatever
it's cause i'm going bald and it sucks
i'm 44 i'm a middle aged man now i like
to think that i'm like a young free
spirit
but i'm starting to thin up here and i
go what are my options right now shave
your head
shave your head yeah comb over man bun
hat uh hair plugs
hair transplant propecia wig sewed right
into your [ __ ] skull
dude i've never thought about it because
shave your head i swear to god i wish
when i first started going bald i would
just shave my head from the beginning
but my my answer to it was
try to dye your hair the same color as
your skin so people don't see your bald
spot
and then i said and then i have like a a
dark week where i'm just like
i'm fat i couldn't keep up with the
tribes the hanzo tribe that's still
feeling old
and well it's when you go i haven't seen
you in a while
you look [ __ ] great man like like
you're always been in shape but
i i've tried trainers before
even like i think i told you last time
and thank you for talking me out of
becoming a ufc fighter
my special you know the korean zombie
yes and i go why did i
why do they call him that it's like
because he can take a punch in it oh
yeah he just keeps going that's my
special skill
every [ __ ] fight i've been in my life
that and i've lost most of them i think
i told you that
i never tap out like you have to break
my arm you have to
i've had my face disfigured so i don't
know that was stupid
i i'm not gonna go into ufc fighting but
i go
i when i think of myself as a person
i i remember myself being relatively
athletic in shape
and when i go oh my hair is going i'm
being fat i can't
run as fast as i can i need a trainer i
need help
but what kind of trainer do i need the
one like you where they're like
hey every morning here sort of like
sergeant drills style or more
hey dave like so i went with both i went
with the hard ass that shows up at my
house dave out of bed i don't give a
[ __ ] runs me till i puke how was that
one
lasted a week out done how many days a
week were you trying to have them on
three monday wednesday friday and after
friday like get the [ __ ] out of here
i just was like this isn't my style like
let me try
this the like soft spoken so i got this
lady claire
shout out to claire and she she would i
told her
i know myself i don't like to be
uncomfortable
like i run from discomfort like right i
want to get in shape but if you push me
too hard
i'm an artist i'm a sensitive being i
don't i'm not i'm not trying to get into
like
fighting shape just get me somewhat
relatively healthy
and then i sort of dropped off with that
too and then the pandemic didn't help so
i'm sitting here and in my brain i'm
like i have a [ __ ] fire in me
i know i can [ __ ]
you know if i i thought when we were
starting the hunt with the tribe
i was like i'm gonna keep up with them
and i did in the beginning it's right in
the front with
the the head guy we're running nona
that's his name
and uh and then i dropped off and and of
course you dropped off but i'm like run
every day you're gonna drop off that's
just part of being a human
i mean it doesn't matter all this fire
in your heart [ __ ]
listen everybody feels that like there's
a reality to
physical fitness and performance and the
big reality is
you got to put in work and recover can i
tell you how it takes forever
can i tell you how i feel when i listen
to the joe rogan experience because i
leave you on all the time when i'm
painting i was listening to when i
painted the thing of you
is i do feel extreme gratitude because
i'm like
even though i've listened to joe for
hundreds of hours now and there's tons
of stuff i do disagree with him
thank god he exists he doesn't have much
of an ego he like
you've always uplifted me promoted me
all your friends
um you have a great sense of humor and
where the [ __ ] was i going with this i
don't know but you're making me
uncomfortable
oh i love it um
[ __ ] where was i going like this this is
what i'm talking about with the memory
and [ __ ] we're talking about the tribes
and then we're talking about uh how soft
we are
and we were talking about how they have
awesome poop and people trying to steal
that poop
i don't know maybe i'll remember it but
it's not funny that you would think that
someone's poop like i know how to become
like him
oh this is oh we're talking about
feelings oh feelings
so i and
you know i love you and i love you too
thanks man i got really uncomfortable
and i and and you have such [ __ ]
powerful people on here that are smart
that are inspiring
that i start to feel self-conscious
and and you have like david gawkins on
it's like dude this fat guy that just
turned his life around
and then i start to really feel less of
a man
self-conscious like a failure
i'm like [ __ ] man if i just if i just
pulled myself up by my bootstraps and i
just
got oh who's who's speaking right now
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] okay okay and
you know which dave was that that's the
dave that tells me i'm a [ __ ] that's
drill sergeant dave
yeah the drill sergeant dave is you know
i got diagnosed with
severe anti-social personality disorder
traits and i said what does that mean
why don't have the actual disorder and
they're like
cause we've never met anyone that's so
[ __ ] hard on themselves
like what's the first thought when you
meet anybody like friend foe anyone
it's [ __ ] you that you think that all
day [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] you who the [ __ ] [ __ ] but the
the strange thing about you is you
actually have friends and people like
you and you have a lot of
people that love you and you love a lot
of people so we can't diagnose you with
the actual disorder
but you [ __ ] have a lot of so you
would see people and just say [ __ ] you
immediately that would be
your i have such insane
abandonment issues my parents sent me
away since i was a kid so i have a
really
weird thing with authority or even
anyone saying
hey david are you open to a suggestion
yeah sure let me hear it and the second
they opened their mouth i'm like [ __ ]
you you don't [ __ ] know me you don't
[ __ ] know me you don't
and it's like so um that's so funny
so i listened to your show and i'm like
damn dude joe [ __ ]
did this he's got all these
inspirational people that turn their
life around like why the [ __ ] do i still
have a gut why can't i
and why why am i still depressed why am
i still addicted to this
why am i why can't i get off the [ __ ]
internet why like
i was talking to you a little bit about
the video game stuff right yeah yeah
when i was in my mid-20s
people couldn't wait for warcraft 3 to
come out it was like the new [ __ ] coming
out
i remember right they're like it's going
to come out and they delayed it
and it finally came out and i didn't i
didn't have any money then and i got
warcraft 2.
and warcraft 2 the interface for the
kids out there listening
um it's like god interface like you're
little peasants and paladins and you're
moving them around where warcraft 3 is
more
3d what the [ __ ] i'm explaining video
games um
and i got on there and because the
entire world was waiting for warcraft 3
no one was playing warcraft 2. so i was
the god
of warcraft 2. you know when you go on
online games you get a game really quick
uh-huh this was back in the this is like
20 years ago so
wait i'm 24. yeah it's like 20 years ago
so i'd get on the game
and i'd be waiting i'd start a map and
i'm like who wants to play and i'd wait
and i have to wait for people to join
my career was just getting started i was
in a wonderful relationship with this
woman and that i dated for seven years
my life was like on the up and up
and this thing completely took over my
life
have you ever seen this documentary
called web junkies about
um the internet problem in china i
haven't seen that but i'm aware of the
problem
it's 2000 it's a documentary from 2014
and it starts with a kid just crying
and they're like why are you crying and
so china had declared
pc rooms internet video game addiction a
national emergency
so they said it's okay we set up these
centers and
you could either poison or drug your kid
and just drop them off there
like or you could lie to them and tell
them they're going to like a camping
trip and then just drop them off there
and then they stay there for 90 days
because that's and it's like a prison
and these the start of the movie yeah
look at the kid crying you see that
wow so so they they can't stop playing
video games they can't stop watching
porn
they can't function so this thing
in the movie at some point i'll spoil it
they escape like
like from uh is this a documentary yeah
it's a documentary
they escape from the mad house at one
point like the kids you know they
form a plan and they where do they go
they go to the pc room down the street
they just can't they can't stop so wow
it almost looks like a independent film
that's why i asked to visit no it's a
documentary the way they've shot it is
very interesting because for me you know
me i don't smoke i don't drink i don't
do any of that
but i [ __ ] i've been to over a
thousand aaa meetings
and i don't drink what people why do you
do that i'm like because i can't stop
porn i can't stop video games i can't
start stop gambling
and i know that they have meetings for
that too but they're harder to find
they're more shameful there's less
people and if i go to aa room and i'm
talking
and there's a guy speaking about how he
got clean from alcohol
i just listen to him and every time he
says alcohol i replace it with porn
video game and i and i and i'm like
and not just that i'll do that in the
last case ditch scenario
but i'll i'll go to all the meetings i
go to all the [ __ ] meetings
and so i'm sitting on warcraft 2
and i'm and i'm something's missing from
my life and my rage and my anger and all
my
my addictions and my my mental illnesses
are coming out in this warcraft game and
i find this map that's perfect it's a
small map
and it's called paintball and it's just
everyone dies everyone has one hit point
so one hit and you're dead so it's more
like a
like a chess speed ball game so the
games don't last more than 15 minutes
you have one peasant one paladin and one
wizard
and i killed at that game i killed
ev and and and within five minutes you
know like
the way it goes you bring down a
blizzard storm and you build a cannon
tower or whatever
and you know if you're gonna win and
this is before five minutes because it's
a fast game
everything moves fast and you don't have
to wait for the wood to chop it's really
fast
and never [ __ ] with those games i
didn't have the this was before the ear
pieces
so within five minutes the game is sort
of on auto so you know it's like who can
do the things the fastest
then i start talking [ __ ] i'm going to
skull [ __ ] your parents you dumb
[ __ ]
this is a kid like oh my god and i'm
like like all you know the way people
talk
like all their demons come out right and
these and i'm playing
kids and they're like why what is a
skull [ __ ] and i'm like
like i am a horrible person and then one
day
i was the king of this map like in this
one
area in my life where my art career is
kind of going good but not really and i
don't know how to be in a relationship
and
i'm just sort of lost in my my mid-20s i
don't know who the [ __ ] i am i don't
in this game i am god i'm god like and
i'll go out and i'll be checked out
i'll be out with my friends hours a day
playing this game
i'm not going to lie it would be like
all day i'd be like oh i got to go work
and so it's the first time in my
lifetime
10 hours a day 12 like
16 18 hours 20 hours a day
so i would play this game and
i would lie i started lying i started
lying to my friends about what i was
doing and when i was out i'd be checked
out they'd be talking about hey what
this new thing we're going to go here
and i'd be like ice storm i storm
you know it's like
dude you're laughing and i could laugh
with you today because it's [ __ ] 20
years ago
but at the time i had
i i had i don't want to admit to you
that i played the [ __ ] game 20 hours
a day
i'd be like yeah i played eight hours
well you no listen i know i had a video
game edition i know
hardcore one right so i get it i get it
but
but see we're older guys i meet kids
today
i was talking to a kid the other day
he's 20 years old and he said
he said i can't get hard and i'm a
virgin
and i and and i said wait hold on back
up
guys like you and me like older dudes
all have the same story of how we saw
our first pornography it's always print
right it's always it's playboy hustler
exactly it's always print it's a naked
photo on a piece of paper
you never had a whole bit about how we
would find it in the forest like yeah
it's in the forest it's in your parents
garage stepfather's garage that's our
generation that's what we found and then
the first time you saw porn how old were
you like physical porn
like with the moving the moving uh i was
in junior high so
13 14. i think i was probably around
there too maybe
maybe i was 14. and pixelated right it's
on the
on the show time with the no i saw
scrambling
tape i saw a vhs tape that was the first
time i ever saw it
my head [ __ ] exploded [ __ ] couldn't
believe
you could see it's crazy because you had
never seen anybody [ __ ] before then like
you kind of knew what vaginas looked
like because the playboy and breasts
look like
but there's something about watching
people actually have sex like your whole
body take it
when you're a 14 year old kid and you
see that it's like a drug
right like a a drug it's not it's not
like a drug it is it is a drug drug i
mean for the kids out there
just don't take it in a pill or a smoke
form but it's a drug we live in a
society today where we have
a strip club a drug dealer a casino it's
all right here you don't have to leave
you remember the vhs tapes that were in
the oh yeah
so i live in a house a small house
three brothers me my older brother my
younger brother and
my head exploded because i saw scrambled
porn at my friend alejandro's place
i was like i think i could see a two
people don't even know what you're
saying when you say scrambled
it's like it's like a it's like my new
paintings there's like glitch like you
see a tit
or whatever but it used to be let's just
explain there used to be there were
certain channels you couldn't get to
and you doubt your parents would have to
subscribe to showtime right but
you take like hbo over an hbo showtime
package you would decide well let's just
get hbo
right we can only afford cinemax but
there were some of those
channels like they'd call cinemax skin
and max right because there's some of
those right
because there was so much they were like
um they were like
fake movies with an excuse to show like
soft core
action but you didn't see penetration no
like
the first time i saw penetration was
when i think
i was 14 i don't remember who got the
video but
some one of my friends got a porn an
actual porn and we were watching it like
in stunned disbelief like
what in the [ __ ] right and so that what
in the [ __ ]
i see the scrambled porn and i can't
function as a normal human now i'm
13 14 years old scrambled i live in a
two-bedroom house
with two like three boys that are all
hitting puberty
and and i i go i need more
i need more whoa so i go i wear my dad's
trench coat
i walk into a uh adult bookstore on uh
la brea in like highland and uh sorry uh
santa monica it's where trejo's tacos is
right now
because i wanted to look like an adult
you know i'm like a [ __ ] like zitty
asian kid and i walk in and you remember
they used to be like
40 bucks and like in a carton they were
like expensive
like the packaging was really big and i
went in there and i
um i saw i saw a package it was like
and i i remember it perfectly
up-and-comers railings
first you know and i'm touching the box
and it's taped up and there's a metal
detector and there's cameras and i go
i i lost my mind i lost my mind i was
like i have to have it
i don't have 40 bucks i'm [ __ ] 13
year old kid i use my fingernail to take
the tape off i take the tape out
and the guy sees that i'm hey what's
going on there [ __ ] jam it on the
coat
book it i run home you gotta wait
there's yeah i i ran all the way that's
when i should have been with the tribe
that's what i guess when you're 13 and
horny
13 and horny and i get home we have a
vhs and a beta machine because my dad
chose wrong and then we had to
eventually get the vhs
and my mom my grandmother is watching
wwf wrestling
so you gotta understand the dynamics of
a tiny home
so my grandma my two brothers and my
parents
and i and someone is always home
someone is always home so i this thing's
burning a hole in my pot i gotta watch
it but when can i watch it
so i finally put a plan together
i go i'm gonna watch this and i don't
even know how to masturbate i don't even
know what that is
i have no sex education i go at dinner
time on wednesday
i'm gonna eat my dinner really quick run
to the [ __ ] living room
and uh so it happened so we're eating
dinner and hey slow down why are you
eating dinner so fast
[ __ ] scoop up the rice get some
kimchi okay hey can i be excused like
no we're having family dinner right now
what's going on tell me
ah no i'm good i'm good i run to the
[ __ ] living room and you can
it's not that far i don't live in a huge
house so you can still hear the
the silverware clinking like they're
eating
i pull out the there's like a disney
movie in there i pull out the vhs i put
in my thing there's the fbi warning i'm
fast forwarding i'm like looking
i'm looking and fast forwarding and you
hit play and fast forward
and then i see tits and it's and and
then she's wearing jeans
and then
that's the cover no no jamie
no don't do this to me i found the
actual video too if you'd like to no no
no no no no time out time out time out
this is outrageous young
actually i don't watch porn outrage
you're making me relapse right now
uh let me see that one more time
so i fast forward to this and you gotta
understand
i had seen print playboy i'd seen i'd
never
seen that right the moving and the
[ __ ] veiny their dicks are and
like you know like i'm like [ __ ] man so
i am
everything's dopamine serotonin you know
i'm like well my dad could walk in at
any second and i'm like
i'm like my i'm pressing my dick against
the wall
and then i was like okay and i'm
studying and i'm like
save this for later this goes in the
spank bank save all okay this is enough
one more second two more seconds
okay delete tape put the disney tape
back in run back and
hey why are you breathing hard why oh
nothing nothing
and then i i get to my room and i share
a bunk bed with my brother
oh no and i'm like are you on top of the
bottom i'm on the bottom
oh no i'm on the bottom that little [ __ ]
could just look down see you at any
moment
so i have i am uh full of there's come
coming out of my eyes
i'm full i'm like i gotta [ __ ] jerk
like i don't even know what
i'm like so and i always knew when my
brother fell asleep because
his breathing slows down so i'm like
sitting there
i'm pressing my dick against the wall
i'm like
you know he's like finally he finally
falls asleep and i go okay
i'm gonna like hold my whole arm because
it's a squeaky it's like a shitty bunk
bed oh no i'm gonna hold my whole arm
against my this and jerk off
[ __ ] dave you knew okay whatever
and am i talking to yourself again i
start doing a very
gentle quiet masturbation but it's still
doing a light tug with a little bit of
squeeze
because i don't want to wake up with my
bro what i want to do is i want to
[ __ ] crank it
and then i hear david it's my brother
why are you shaking the bed so much i'm
like oh [ __ ] man
like and now i'm like god damn i gotta
find a place in my
anyways i could go on and on about my
brother's a [ __ ] blocker he's a [ __ ]
blocker he [ __ ] cocked me
blocked me for myself so i bring this up
because
this is this is what we had to do to
bust the nut in the back in the day it's
not that hard today it's everywhere
so i meet this 20 year old kid and he
goes i'm a virgin
i i've heard your story before because
your story is every old guy story
my story is my mom was watching me she
left the youtube video
baby shark or some [ __ ] up and i she
went to the bathroom and i clicked
pokemon and then it was pokemon cosplay
triple anal
gangbang and that's the first thing i've
ever seen
at age four whoa straight to anal
age four how it's how is that possible
dude if you have an unblocked phone like
it's very hard he's a kid going to get
to pokemon porn is it that quick
jamie is that back in the day
that could have happened is this also
like back in the day when youtube
used to have it set up with like did
they have restrictions back in the day
because when if when things first
started going up there was a lot of
people sneaking things in
yeah that weren't supposed to be on
there and then they would catch them
but they didn't have porn none of those
none of those have had like
i don't think so but i think people can
probably get away it could probably be
up there for like five minutes before it
gets taken down or something
you know what's so crazy is that twitter
still has porn right hardcore
right like if you let let your kid look
at your phone and they click on
twitter they could see someone taking
the ass i have a blocked phone
yeah that could happen so whoa so this
kid's like
that's my story and that's most young
people's story now it isn't they found
their dad's playboy in the forest i
accidentally stumbled upon
or some kid that doesn't it wasn't an
accident someone tells you some older
brother
goes hey so my first visual burned
programmed into my young mind isn't a
still image with a
woman with a huge bush it's [ __ ] anal
penetration
that's my first image and as the addict
craves novelty as you get older you need
more and more so by the time i'm 13
i've already that's i need prolapsed
anus stuff i need
transsexual i need gay sex i need
so he says this kid is 20 years old he's
never had sex
he's like a what a simp in cell whatever
they call him
he uses viagra to get half hard he can't
even get fully hard
and it's his life is just scrolling it's
just
porn video games porn video games porn
and it's
we could sit here and we could laugh at
it and i have laughed at it
but this is that's a problem that's a
problem so
if i take it back to when i'm 24 when
the technology was way less
i missed my first deadline i was late to
work i didn't i
i lost that girlfriend not just because
of that because other issues too but
i didn't get up for one weekend from
friday to sunday without pissing
drinking water and at some point i had
found my
this guy this arch enemy on this
warcraft game he'd win one i'd win one
more one more one more
he'd win one one more and the guy was
like a british guy who had a wife and
kids he's like bro
i got a life dude and i'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] we go we go we go
hours hours i'm seeing [ __ ] wizardry
in my mind i'm seeing paladins i'm
seeing them or
i i feel like god when i finally got up
i [ __ ] collapsed my legs were gone
and then
i almost had to call 9-1-1 because they
just wouldn't work for an
hour and i called my friend who's a
doctor and they're like you're
dehydrated go drink some water
and if jamie just googles korean video
game overdose
it's always a korean it's always an
asian they play video games to death
there's a korean family why do you think
that is the culture there
it's like intense that's like it's uh
if we think we stuff like
the the addiction that most people if
you play whack-a-mole you're like hey i
used to be addicted to sex
gambling and i jump and i jump and i'm
addicted to this the one where you can
hide in plain sight where everyone pats
you on the back is workaholism right
i could work all day and night and in
this
culture you get pat on the back asian
culture is the same except if you
fail you either kill yourself and you're
an absolute disgrace and you know it's
like
um in japan it was the suicide rate was
really high now it's in korea
but it's all your identity is tight like
who are you oh i'm
a podcaster i'm this you are only what
your job is and if you're not good at it
then what's your drug oh i'm going to
[ __ ] just
zone out in this video game pc room my
life's not going well
there's a there's a man and a wife in
korea
i saw this in some documentary that they
would keep going to the internet room
to play this video game like where you
virtually raised like the sims or
something like that
that they forgot to feed their own kid
and their kid died and they went to jail
for it and then when they went out it's
like this is a [ __ ] problem
this is like a real problem and
we live in a culture where there's
things that are accepted addictions
right if you
[ __ ] do opioids and heroin and like
i've been to those rooms man i see how
they treat people if you're like a
heroin addict there's a hierarchy you're
a real drug addict
but if you smoke weed come on man you're
not gonna od from that
but if if you look at the amount of
people that kill themselves now like
it's almost normalized and how many of
my friends have done that how many of
you
people that you know that and especially
during this pandemic the suicide rate's
gone up like crazy
that's a [ __ ] real problem man like
and people
when i think of bourdain and i think of
myself and even starting the show off
giving you compliments
we live in a culture that doesn't know
how to
when people go don't shoot the messenger
the messenger
people say that because the messenger
gets shot we don't know how to ask for
help
we don't know how to receive help we
don't know even how to give help like
if i try to help one of my friends who's
like addicted to video games and jerking
off
get the [ __ ] out of here dave you don't
[ __ ] i'm like bro just trying to help
right it's very hard to help people they
have to want help
right if people don't want help you're
not going to help them you're going to
bully them around you're going to yell
at them they're going to eventually do
what they want to do anyway
but when someone comes to you and says
hey i need help that's when things get
serious
because other than that you're forcing
like i have friends that i would like
if they did things differently in terms
of their health but
i can't say anything to them like i just
you just have to accept it
this is what it is you know they people
come up with their own excuses
their own reasons you brought this up
early and i wanted to ask you now like
you were talking about like physical
stuff like you get
angry and you get anxiety because like
you
you don't you you let yourself get
overweight like
how much does that [ __ ] with you and how
much
would you give to not have that anymore
like isn't that wouldn't i mean if
there's one major thing that keeps
[ __ ] with you over and over again
that you could fix i have that's a fixed
one
like you could fix that one so i have a
disease of more like i was saying that i
have a
chasm a black hole that it doesn't
matter
how many women i have sex with how many
porn i've jerked off to
how much money i've gambled and lost in
one
small fortunes huge fortunes i have had
an eating disorder
which is like i thought that was
a girl thing that's what i thought like
i got to when i went to rehab
for gambling addiction it was this is
the first rehab i've went
to i've been to every [ __ ] rehab
mental health wellness center in america
now
um i said hey do you guys deal with
process addiction and they're like i
sure come over and when i went there
there was only meth heads there
they didn't even know they just wanted
my money yeah i just come over here
and i learned there like serious
gambling addiction
like one out of four kills themselves
and yeah it's it's
a it's the reason why there's no
balconies in las vegas
the only place that has balconies is the
cosmo i think and they had like two
suicides the first month they opened
i think because you're
so i i i'm like i have things
that when i talk about it it's funny
can't stop jerking off
can't it's all i can't stop working just
[ __ ]
got a emmy working for vice and i got my
podcast and i got this and i got this
next project and my next art show's
going to make a million dollars
you're addicted to that there's no end
to it right there's no
there's no nothing and when i meet when
i watch the jordan documentary and i
meet famous people that have succeeded
at the highest levels i go how long were
you happy for
maybe a day maybe 24 hours and then what
happens the next day
back to the grind it's not enough got
the gold medal back to the grind
back to the grind and i go it's
it's never going to be enough i'll never
have enough
women money success
it's it's this and i go i have so many
friends who've killed themselves i have
so many
like bourdain asked me for help he asked
me for help like
i'm like yes what did he say he said i'm
[ __ ] miserable
i'm miserable do you how do you deal
with this and i was like i've been
waiting for this [ __ ] phone call
thank you
how how recent or how close to when he
died was that
it was within the year it wasn't like
right but so he said it was miserable
and
in what way to describe it he said
you're successful i'm successful
do you find yourself suffering and i go
absolutely please and then i called him
and uh and i this is what i mean when i
say
asking for help and receiving for help
that was a [ __ ] heart
you know people that know bourdain i
know his friends i know his manager
you won't find a [ __ ] person that
will say a bad thing about him
that guy is a [ __ ] he's so awesome
he's
always looking out for you he'll show up
for you whatever you need he'll take
care of you he's an amazing guy
very very interesting guy and so you
can't find anyone but i'm like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you're an
[ __ ] you murdered
yourself you murdered yourself you
killed someone that person happened to
be you
but you couldn't even show up for
yourself you
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm getting real listen i get
it you love the guy
i loved him too it's um
i've known many people that have killed
themselves now
it's uh it's a very sad thing
that was that you can't you can never
fix that that sadness is always going to
be a part of you you're always going to
think
maybe i could have gotten to him maybe i
could have talked to him maybe if i was
there
but that was it he he did it he reached
out he's like i relate to you dave
i connect with you and i was like yes
so what did he wind up doing he i talked
to him
i said hey man here's all the things
i've done i'm i'm in a really good place
now i can help you i can
i can refer you to places i got you and
it was almost like
thank you for caring for me thank you
like he was he was
severe codependent like he was a people
pleaser right he's like i'm
like he never said no he's like i'm
gonna [ __ ]
help everybody except for myself
it's okay man i get it
so i'm gonna help everyone except for
myself
and i think i make this up in my head
he's like
and i've done this too before it's like
i kind of
half-ass ask people for help oh dave i
got resources and i go
that's enough just to know that you
cared and that i know that there's
places i can go to
that's enough i don't have to actually
full stop my life
and change until
you know oh [ __ ] so that's what i mean
when i say
we don't as a culture people don't teach
us this [ __ ] people don't teach us how
how to how to [ __ ] ask for help and
then receive help and
i i [ __ ] gave you five compliments at
the start of the show i i can't i
couldn't take a [ __ ]
i couldn't take a compliment i couldn't
say one
nice thing about myself five years ago
and if someone tries to say something
hey dave you're good i'd shut him down
okay okay it's like
and i turn ever i turn everything into a
joke
right everything i can't sit here in
this discomfort i don't want to be
uncomfortable so i find i find this
place
i go i i'm [ __ ] ready now i'm ready
whatever my best thinking got me here
like whatever
talking to people sitting around like
i something's [ __ ] up with me
all the [ __ ] that happened in my my life
i'm like
throwing myself in a [ __ ] jungle with
like i'm going to jail repeatedly hold
on hold
why are you choosing to look at it in a
negative way in the way you're
describing it right there but something
must be [ __ ] up with me
i go to the jungle i'm doing all this
crazy [ __ ] that's one of the things that
makes you interesting
is this extreme real curiosity
you have a a real curiosity and a
willingness to do
wild [ __ ] like go to the congo and look
for a [ __ ] dinosaur
and sleep in attendance i'm telling you
this is crawling around i'm telling you
this story now
because i'm alive i could have easily
died there
yeah multiple times yeah and then going
back yes going back 10 years later yeah
i think
a film crew is going to make that easier
i get it but the [ __ ] chief's
sister had a machete in her mouth and
it's like let's kill these [ __ ]
and i'm like why am i back here why
didn't why did they want to kill you
because they thought we were uh they
wanted money and we
we had used all our we gave them all our
money for filming rights
and the the sister was like they have
more like he was like the evil warlord
of
it wasn't the pygmies see
no i still look it's not you're looking
at it
you're what what makes you interesting
you're looking at it as a negative
one of the things that makes you
interesting is that you're a wild person
who takes chances
that's why i told you you should do a
podcast look joe
that's but dave it's not a bad thing all
these things you're saying
are not bad things can it be both i
don't know man i mean i think
can i teach you what i learned yes
the way i'm talking to you right now is
how i talked
coming into like these loony bins that
i've been to
they're like wow the way you talk is
very black
and white [ __ ] this this is bad this is
the [ __ ] bomb this is the [ __ ]
this is lit this is fire this is [ __ ] i
don't even know i said that i don't talk
like that
it's like it's like i was in the parking
lot in korea town
and i'm like i'm looking at the next
generation of koreans they got
[ __ ] in their face they got piercings i
watched these two korean kids talk to
each other
for 20 minutes and they only said bruh
lit
and fire and i'm like what the [ __ ] did
you guys just say uh
anyways um because of my religious
background where it's
heaven or hell god's way or satan you
kind of look at everything like that
right joe rogan is the best that podcast
is the worst
so you ask me right now why do i look it
in this bad way and i go
can it be both because you don't have a
gray there's no 50 shades of grey
there's it's just black and white
it's only the best and the worst that's
if you could you feel something if you
[ __ ] come off a big win
yes i just want a [ __ ] ton of money in
vegas i did this i did that
or if you get canceled but in here in
the middle
you feel nothing so you got to go for
the highs and usually
you feel more when you lose so you chase
the lose like
you don't [ __ ] get it what dave
you're gonna [ __ ] it
i like losing you don't [ __ ] get it i
like feeling [ __ ]
you almost died in the congo why are you
going back because i because maybe they
didn't get you know
so i get the thrill out of escaping the
jaws of death
there's something severely broken in me
that
i get a fix i get a hit i get it and the
thing is
you've heard heroin addicts that say i
get this high now
just to feel even i don't even get
that's where i was at
i'm i'm [ __ ] playing angry birds till
my [ __ ] finger is split open
i'm [ __ ] gambling you say but you're
not saying current tense no no no
i'm telling old stories right i know but
you're saying it now
right no no no no this is i'm i'm i'm
soft-serving now
i'm [ __ ] smelling flowers you still
you channeled dave of old yeah well
that's another dave that's inside of you
david hey you driving the bus right now
you want to sit in the back or you want
to
come back okay you know what jamie you
into dead air
can can i can i just do 10 seconds to
get back to
sure
this is the weirdest podcast we've ever
done thank you thank you so much i need
like
because i'm hyped up you saw that you
saw old dave come up and i want to
i want to amp it up i want to keep going
high
this is awesome man so i so
i i i can't like you meet people
and you're like you're wired this way
and
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
and that's just joe rogan that you see
today in his 30s and his 40s and 50s
it's gonna still be that but a little
different version of that
when he's 56 and i meet these guys i
mean i
most of these places are very expensive
and the people that end up there
it's like everyone has cut them out so
they have to be there
or they lost their job so i'm usually
the youngest guy there i'm independently
wealthy so i can pay for it
and i'm looking at these guys that have
everything
they have all the money all the fame
every everything
and they're successful only in their
career everything else they're a failure
at their kids hate them their wives ate
them they're
and i go
i gotta [ __ ] i gotta rewire myself
like i i can't live like this because
you go why is this good or bad and i'm
like because i don't care if i live
i'm ready to die i want to die like i
i wait a minute but you enjoy life today
i do
today i do sometimes in the time that
you met me i really
probably didn't enjoy life so much it's
more
everything feels like a chore everything
feels like i'm underwater
like now no not now now every now and
then now i do
like so part part of that is the thing
leaning into discomfort but what got you
over the hump
like there's a lot of people that have
experienced what you're describing so
what got you to the point where
now it's all flowers and and happy
friends
friends isn't that that that
is one of the most underappreciated
recipes
you have people that will die for you i
have people that will die for me that is
a [ __ ] rare commodity in this world
and when i say friends i mean they left
me
i i thought i was a genius i was like
whatever the [ __ ] you see with kanye
that's what i thought i'm like i'm a
genius i'm doing and and there was
the people that were like you are a
genius dave you are great and i go you
don't get it dude
i want to [ __ ] die right now i want a
cop to come out and shoot me
because i'm [ __ ] his wife right now
that's what i want that's a [ __ ]
crazy story for the podcast dave
that's i i'm not living i'm not no one's
home hello
no one's home and so my friends say
we're done with you
wait you're my homies down for life
right right or die we're
[ __ ] done with you who who who the
[ __ ] are we to you
who are we to you you've i've have
friends that i've known since i was
eight years old i'm 44 now
my whole life they go and so in a moment
of clarity like the same way i didn't
[ __ ] kill the german guy
i go wait every person in my life that i
chose
to have a friendship with is telling me
i'm an [ __ ]
that that i'm not me anymore that i'm
not making sense that i need help
and i and the thing is i know i need
help but i'm like
why did i get sent away when i was a kid
there's three boys
why did i get sent away because you were
the well most well-behaved
you know we didn't have enough money to
raise three boys so we sent you away
because you didn't cry you didn't cause
problems so i'm a kid now i'm four years
old when i get sent away
the wiring is how long do you get sent
away for for one year
to korea i don't know who i don't speak
the language i don't know who these
people are and there was no
explanation there was no i just woke up
one day i'm having the best time with my
brothers and they're like
bye my mom's crying like why are you
crying [ __ ] what the [ __ ] going on
bye i'm all of a sudden in this smelly
country
and and so i'm like i'm trash i'm trash
yeah i'm [ __ ] worthless you don't
give a [ __ ] you could just
explain to you nobody explained nobody
explained [ __ ] so now i'm wired
when they do explain oh when you get
sent away
because you're good good behavior is
punished
why didn't my brother get sent away he
was crazy he was like
he was a problem child he was like
chucky he was like he got into this
thing to do what did you do when you got
to korea it was just to live with my
uncles and my aunts and
and just to have other families support
me because my parents weren't doing too
well financially
so then the whole concept of nice guys
finished last
right right so i'm this quiet asian guy
and you could just say whatever you he's
a pushover you keep getting
[ __ ] up you get [ __ ] over [ __ ]
over the guy with the eyes outside the
then i get out of jail what do i get
sold out show in new york city
dave cho says whatever the [ __ ] he wants
does whatever the
worst i act the look at what's happening
to trump right now kanye
you act as shitty as you can and you get
[ __ ]
gap deals and presidencies and you never
[ __ ] apologize
you never calm down dave calm down
the dave of old so you so my thinking is
acting right acting like the model
minority acting like the good little
asian boy
got me nowhere when i talk a fool when i
do whatever the [ __ ] i want
when i [ __ ] when i fight when i gamble
when i act crazy
i get television deals i get on howard
stern i get on [ __ ] joe rogan
i get [ __ ] uh sold out art shows
women
they pause you okay do you think that
you are the victim
of the attention that you were getting
do you think you leaned into it and it
became
who you decided you were because that
was giving you the most love
and people got a kick out of the fact
that you genuinely didn't give a [ __ ]
so you just leaned into that so it
changed you it's absolutely that
but it's more nuanced than that there's
a lot it's everything well i'm already
mentally unstable
four-year-old thing man right that's it
that's right
i mean when that i mean that's the
[ __ ] that's the gasoline
that was poured all over you so things
don't make sense to me
they can't make sense to you man and as
an adult i go
i have wealth i have money i know famous
people who have wealth
why we know the story rich famous
uh [ __ ] blow your brains out hang
yourself we know that that
doesn't have to you're alive right now
unless it doesn't have to ever go down
that way
but when when the one thing that you've
got to know
is you can't fix any of the [ __ ] that
happened to you
that's that's a that's a real problem
because the [ __ ] that happened to you
was titanic for that to happen to you at
four years of age
as you're growing up and developing to
hit us a
horrible situation like that at four
through no fault of your own
that all of it makes sense it's what we
were talking about
that everybody doesn't starve from the
same spot you know
and it's it's what makes unfortunately
it's what makes people so goddamn
interesting sometimes too
whether it's joey diaz or whether it's
you or most of my friends that are
really
interesting had these [ __ ] up lives
that you would never want to wish upon
your kid but see
when you say that i hear that and i love
it and respect you so i go
i this is just how i feel i go
joe loves me because i'm weird and i'm
interested no no no no and for me no i'm
saying how i i remember
and i need to stay [ __ ] up to be
interesting
for me to get help who can i look to
who navigated their way out of this
jungle
who did it right who can i look up to go
man that guy was wild crazy
he did all this crazy [ __ ] he got rich
and famous and whatever and then he
sailed half
like where where can i find that and i
go
no i just accept i'm not
you know yes i've had suicidal ideation
yes i'm [ __ ] mentally disturbed yes
i've had to
go to jail and lock myself up many times
but
at least i'm rich you know like let me
stop you again
okay here's the thing to concentrate on
what is the goal if the goal is to be
happy
right the problem is a lot of people are
doing things to be successful
could be because they think becoming
successful is what makes you happy
it doesn't always sometimes you feel
empty and you feel angry that you spend
all your time
working for something that you don't
even appreciate when it's over
but you're on paper you're successful
that's not really successful
can i tell you one of the can i tell you
a story of how i got better and let me
hold you okay one second this is what i
want to get to yes
some people are happy right would we
would can we say that
do you think some people you think
there's a percentage of this population
that's happy
some people are happy yes of course some
people are happy okay
there's no characteristics that exclude
you from that group
you could also be happy and i say this
to anybody anybody
who's been happy but how joe but
this is what you got to do concentrate
on what it is
first of all that makes you happy and i
guarantee you for a big part of it for a
lot of people is their physical health
improve your physical health you'll
improve your enthusiasm you'll improve
your energy
and you'll improve your ability to
absolutely do other things
you'll be happier right and then do what
you're doing
you've already you've already gone on to
this great path where you've changed
basically
who you are you've become like this this
guy is more introspective
can i tell you just growing up in
america
part of being a man because someone
asked me where's your idea of
a man come from i go from clint eastwood
watching guy movies growing up you know
the way korean men are so macho and
so that's in me and what is what is that
what is being a man it's like
shut the [ __ ] up and take handle your
business don't ask for help
yes korean asians we don't like asking
for help
we never ask for help and so when i tell
you
that i've been to every [ __ ] mental
health institution
and like there's sick people all over
the country in the world
i never saw one [ __ ] asian guy until
i saw one
for [ __ ] five years i'm going to all
these places and i'm and i
just don't ask for help they don't ask
for help you just
suffer silently there's people listening
right now that are suffering
like because you know what they do the
story i've just told you right now i
wasn't able to say that for years
because i made trauma a competition
big [ __ ] deal you left your parents
sent you away
you weren't starving in korea i'm like
i'm four years old dude i don't know
where my [ __ ] parents are yeah but
your grandpa
he has this big ginseng farm you're
having a nice life out there
okay you know what there's someone else
down the street getting [ __ ] molested
getting beaten i don't everyone tries to
do this like hierarchy of like
i got it this bad shut the [ __ ] up who
are you and i go
but everyone's pain is maximum to them
right
everyone's maximum pain is right so you
when you're getting
hurt when someone's doing this and to
someone a big deal that doesn't hurt my
feelings and i go but to me it does
i'm not thinking well you know there's
people getting killed in the streets
right now so i have no
i'll say that to myself there's people
getting killed in the streets right now
so just because one guy said
go back to where you come from i have no
i i'm gonna quiet up
zip i'm not gonna say anything because
what is that that's nothing that's a
oh you hurt me with your words but i go
but it did
your words hurt me and well you're not
allowed to feel that
and yet i do i feel [ __ ] and my whole
[ __ ] life
my is reactionary to stop that by
building walls and come up with these
coping mechanisms
and i go teach me i want to [ __ ]
learn
and they go you're not going to like it
and you already know because i already
talked about here
step one was i was like i'll do anything
and they're like it's not gonna happen
overnight
and then someone said there is something
that will happen overnight ayahuasca i'm
like i'm in
i'm an addict i want it quick i
love you because you do [ __ ]
psychedelics i don't know what kind of
person you would be if you didn't like
it changed my life i did ayahuasca 30
when i was 35 years old so almost nine
years ago
and it [ __ ] the the trip i had in the
jungle in colombia
and they told me this isn't going to
change your life but it'll kick the
doors open
for you to begin to become a different
person and
we're sitting here we're sitting on
[ __ ] microphones there's this and
this
there's other dimensions there's [ __ ]
and it's like i can't
i'm i'm telling you i agree with
everything you said i
when i exercise i feel great when but i
there's something
i i'm an addict i'm a [ __ ] up i can't
teach me i i need something besides and
this is why i said
when i listen to all the motivational
stuff and i and i get fired up i go yeah
if i just [ __ ] got up and push myself
and i go
but that's not me i need something more
and i'm gonna [ __ ] be
curious i'm gonna search and so i get to
a place where
they go dave you turn everything into a
joke
you lie a lot right starting with
up what's up every guy answer to how are
you doing i don't care if your dad just
died or you just got
a divorce great okay right okay is not a
feeling good is not a feeling
something horrible i could have had the
worst day right now and if you ask me
how you're doing i'd say
good i'm okay and that would be a lie so
i go what
i'm going to go to a place in
mississippi i i'm not going to say the
name i don't know if there's like
lawsuit [ __ ] but
i went there and it's a mandatory place
for crooked judges uh congress
like hi like doctors lawyers
and they have to be there and they have
to relearn
rewire or else they don't get their um
you know licenses back to practice
whoa and i was the only one there by
choice i didn't have to be there
and so i get there and they go why are
you here and i go i can't stop
thinking a certain way i can't stop
lying i can't stop exaggerating i can't
stop storytelling
i can't stop period i have
uncontrollable behavior
i'm impulsive and i don't like who i am
and i'm suicidal
at times and i i i want and they go
we're gonna do something here so they
they took the yellow stick it pads and
they wrote
no joking
so they put one on here and here and
they go
no more joking and they taught me
different ways to like
that guy sounds like a bummer total
bummer and they can actually joke and
they can act like
they go we know that this place that
you're at right now is not how the real
world exists
but while you're here and by the way you
could leave at any time
we're going to ask you to to change
your behavior so what was the problem
they had with you joking that was your
defense mechanism for him every
[ __ ] serious thing right oh here's
the [ __ ] i was better
i was better at the company i told you
before when i saw you do that thing in
la
that did at ucla i'm like you could be a
comic you 100 could be a comic
you have a comics mentality you're
[ __ ] up like a comic
you have crazy ideas like a comic and
you're insightful
you're a smart guy you'd be really good
at it thank you for saying that and
100 like you're there's comics you meet
in life obviously you're a multifaceted
guy you can do a lot of different things
you're a great artist you can do
whatever you want
but there's something about
comics that never became comics there's
a lot of them i
worked for one at one point time i
worked for a private investigator
dave dolan the most [ __ ] hilarious
guy i've ever met in my life totally was
a comic just never did comedy i met a
bunch of guys like that
were totally comics they just never
found comedy like if they did they'd be
one of us they'd be hanging out in the
back of the comedy store can you admit
that you can draw like relatively good
yeah i could draw relatively okay so you
know through everything else you've
achieved in your life if you practice
you'd be awesome at it but you said the
same thing
that's funny dave you're going to keep
asking me to paint i'm not going to do
it i know
who i am i get obsessed and whatever
when i walked off the stage at ucla
i did two hours like improv
and i and i invited like harris whittles
rest in peace he's not here anymore i
invited comic writers and i said
shoot me straight like don't do the like
dave you were great they were like you
[ __ ] killed
two you've never done comedy before and
you killed for two hours
there's some rusty parts but if you just
kept the reps in
and then similarly i've always always
wanted to be in a band right
so uh mca from beastie boys passes away
and then money mark who's been touring
with them for 20 years is out of work
he's a friend of mine
and i'm like i've known you for a while
why don't we [ __ ] make a ban
we do us i formed the band maangchi we
uh with bobby lee's brother steve lee is
the singer and money mark
we [ __ ] tour the us and we sell out
like two
small like two 300 cedar clubs
and every [ __ ] um uh high school
like rock band fantasy is fulfilled and
at our last show i think bill burr was
there
i'm like we're playing here in los
globos in silver lake
and i'm playing to this sold out 200
it's all my friends my family
there's comedians there's porn stars and
there's like a super famous
you know uh one of the most famous uh
rock band lead singers in the audience
and he's like
can i talk to you after the show i'm
like yeah and he's like
i play to like 20 30 000 seat stadium
people now and what you just took me
back to was
our first days when we started i would
do
anything for that and i sat there and i
was like wait
joe rogan told me i like i don't think
he's bullshitting he thinks i could
really do this comedy thing
i felt i felt like on fire when i was on
stage
this guy's telling me if i just keep
touring and i keep putting out videos
that at some point i'll be selling out
500 1000 and then in five years
and i go i love playing music i love
comedy
and i think i've tasted just enough
where i don't want to [ __ ] i
you would these things take time man to
[ __ ] perfect it and craft it you've
done this for
thousands of hours like i i said
in this and this is all like after i've
done a lot of work on myself
i'm like i'm going to walk away from
this as someone who doesn't know how to
say no
and and like i have that overachieving
attitude i'm like
why not why not did you have a good time
on stage
yeah i loved it did you love them when
people laughed yeah it was like a drug i
felt it
do you want to keep doing that and the
torture of coming up with new material
and like
you know and the bands if you don't like
i'm like i know myself well enough now
that i i'm gonna stick to one thing at a
time
you know so
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you the story
and i you know i could tell you jail
stories porn star i have all these
stories but the [ __ ]
weirdest [ __ ] that i've ever done in my
life was to go to this place
and it's like an intensive outpatient
place so i have an apartment with a
roommate i haven't a [ __ ] roommate in
years
and they go in the time that you're here
once again
voluntarily you can leave at any time
we're gonna ask you to [ __ ] do
everything you say it's
counter-intuitive to who you are
and the way you're wired but we're going
to ask you to tell the truth
and just [ __ ] and i go yeah sure i
can do that
i don't even i haven't even checked into
my apartment i'm opening the door i
cohen
there is a man that's obesely overweight
sitting on a couch
in his [ __ ] tidy he looks like he's
naked because his gut is covering his
white underwear
and he's watching uh walter white i see
walter white he's watching breaking bad
and he's on the couch like this
are you my new roommate don't tell me
don't tell me
bro i don't even [ __ ] know you don't
tell on you what it's like
i like to do meth and get really [ __ ]
up and go to um uh bath houses and let
mexican guys suck my dick
and i'm like whoa [ __ ] and this guy
i don't know where he's from
specifically they had to be mexican
we got into it later his name was paco
it's like mexican guys and i take my
stomach
and they have to find my dick and i hit
their head with my stomach when i whoa
i go yeah i said it's a fetish right and
i go
this guy sounds like he wants to get
caught like
i'm like don't tell on me and so what do
i go yeah okay fine whatever
so the next day we go into the rooms and
the
every morning starts with community we
sit in the circle here it's like does
anyone have any agenda items they want
to put in
and i go you know what i got on a
[ __ ] plane to come to mississippi
i paid the money i raised my hand
let's let's call this guy walter because
i was watching walter white that's not
his name
i go walter was watching um breaking bad
this guy what the [ __ ] dave what what
the [ __ ] your pr i thought we were
roommates i thought you were my homie
that's not how he talks he talked more
right what the hell dave what the [ __ ]
you doing man
and um i go i'm here
i'm a [ __ ] rat i'm i go
this is not how i talk back at home i
don't tell on people it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] you you go we know
dave
just while you're here we're gonna train
you and then whatever sticks
we want you to be about your word when
you say something and i
don't i don't see how this is helping me
you're severe codependent
you don't know how to show up for
yourself you don't know how to say no
people just take and take people run
over you we're teaching you how to stand
up for yourself
am i a [ __ ] a grown man i need to
learn how to yes
yes you weren't taught this you weren't
taught this [ __ ]
you learned from movies and [ __ ] your
dad didn't speak the language perfectly
you don't have any [ __ ] no one taught
you these simple things
how to show up for yourself how to stand
up for yourself
like oh [ __ ] and this guy's huge he's
like a obese guy
and immediately i have to apologize
sorry man
i'm not sorry that's what i'm here for
but i have to have him like me
so the session the class ends sorry dude
sorry walter i'm sorry
why'd you do that dave i thought we were
friends i'm like dude i'm here i'm
trying to get better
and i go i have these things on my thing
on my legs that say no joking and i go
i gotta crack a joke with this guy i
gotta [ __ ] like make him like me
again
i go how do you wipe your ass dude and
i'm like what are you talking about
because we have a tiny shower
and he's he's [ __ ] humongous he's
like morbidly obese
he's like dave man no like
no one ever asked me questions like this
man are you my friend
and this guy is this guy had in his
regular life was like a high power
something
like in government what yeah every
minute he's doing math he's morbidly
obese
yeah and he has a high power position in
government he's
let's just say he's a professional like
he and
so i'd never been to a place like this
where every person there
no matter what you say they put you on a
lie detector at the end of the week
they go cool cool story and and i'm like
wow they wanna hold you accountable they
really really wanna you gotta be on
so so i'm i'm like
and then so i become friends with this
guy over the week and like i'm like okay
cool
i hope he still likes me and he goes
dave you're not like anyone else here
everyone else here is like some kind of
professional and like you got the weird
hair you dressed like a homeless guy
like
are you famous or something i feel like
i seen you somewhere and i'm like no
and i had just taken a class on how to
uh
hold a boundary and stand up for myself
i said walter
while we're here together i'm going to
ask you
just know me as david your roommate and
if you want to google me when we leave
here and the thing is he
everyone has different privileges one of
his is he doesn't have a phone
so he couldn't look me up or whatever
i'm going to ask you
this is my boundary please just know me
as your roommate
and if you want to look me up when i
leave you know it's like okay i could do
that
i get home that night i [ __ ] knew
i saw you on tv man you're the facebook
guy you're the [ __ ]
you know so my normal
okay cool whatever i asked you you
didn't do it
and uh i go to my room and i'm like
[ __ ] man that really that really chaps
my head you know i'm like i asked you
and then now he has all the questions
man you're rich did you do this i read
this story about you on why do you have
a [ __ ] roommate
that's part of the thing right that's
and i sit in my room and i go once again
i gotta i'm here why don't i just
experience this fully so i go out in the
other room and i go hey walter
i asked you today not to do that and i'm
i'm like kind of shaking because like i
don't talk to people this way i just i
bury [ __ ] i just like let things go i
and it i get turned into a passive
aggressive person so i go tomorrow at
community
i'm gonna have to call you but please
please don't please don't do that come
on
and actually he went to anger first he's
like his build is like this giant guy
he's he's hitting the table his foot
dave what the [ __ ] man i'm one week away
don't
and i'm like one week away from what
from getting out he was almost done
by the way what does time feel like to
you right now like is it going fast or
slow
it's regular it must be slow as [ __ ] in
there
well the way people are explaining this
pandemic or the quarantine i'm like this
is jail time
like when people are like waiting for
when when am i going to get out
and when do you get out when you're on
good behavior when does society get out
when you're on good behavior when people
start listening
yeah and when you're on bad behavior
stay longer oh my god we're gonna close
the bars down again
so he he goes he starts getting really
physically threatening and
part of what i love about wearing masks
now
is i don't know what your interaction
with your fans in public have been since
you become famous is
people try to break my hand when they
shake my hand do they really they try to
break my hand
or they they think they're going to have
more impact if they talk close to my
face
so they try to crush your fingers they
do this what's up man and then they hold
it and then i
you know normal and then they hold on to
it and they do a little squeeze at the
end i go what the f
dick flexing [ __ ] was that you know
weird flex bro and and so
um and then people do the close face
talking and i hate
so this guy's like dude you know he's
using his his girth to just like
intimidate you and i'm like and i'm like
this is during corona or no
no this is like years ago
and i say i say you know what i would
love walter
if you told on yourself if i didn't have
to because that's one thing you could do
oh and he gets really angry and then he
calms down
and uh he goes uh
i'm gonna do it dave i'm gonna do it i'm
like yes [ __ ] yeah
i'm i'm changing as a person i'm
learning skills i'm learning tools
we go to community the next morning and
uh
i'm waiting we're going in a circle and
i'm like [ __ ] dude do it i don't want to
call you out bro
and he goes yeah i got something i want
to put on the agenda this morning
um at an interaction with
one of the other patients here and we
worked it out and i'm gonna take care of
it
and i was like what what the [ __ ] was
that and i go hold up hold up
hey walter [ __ ] i asked him not to
google me and
and the the therapists are like that's a
complete violation of the anonymity
rights here
and and he's like
this is and and now all the information
this is your 12th time
[ __ ] violating a patient's you tried
he tried to [ __ ] the roommate that was
in the room before me
like um the guy was sad and he was
giving him a hug and he tried to finger
his butthole when he was giving him a
hug oh boy
he doesn't have phone privileges so he
asked another patient can i
use your phone to call my wife he calls
his wife
and then that's what he says and then he
gives the thing back to the phone
uh to the other patient and then 10
minutes later he starts getting dick
pics from paco with his mexican
boyfriend
that he only [ __ ] when he's on meth
right i'm not gay only when i'm on meth
and so they're like and so i'm like [ __ ]
this guy hates me but i'm like
no he's out of he's breaking bad he's
out of control
and i go oh [ __ ] and he's not on meth
while he's
in that house no no well i don't know he
might have been and because he's
he's acting like messed up so they're
like that was your last strike you're
out of here
and pack your bags and you know your
wife's gonna pick you up tomorrow
morning and i'm like
so i i go ex this is me i'm like i did
the right thing and i go immediately to
shame and guilt
i'm like [ __ ] he i take the i become
it's my fault he's getting kicked out
because of me like oh
[ __ ] and and i raised my hand again i go
i don't feel safe
sleeping in that room tonight can i you
know some other guys like yeah you could
crash
on our couch and i go okay so i'm like
wow
this is crazy like i'm standing up for
myself i i haven't ever done this i
haven't ever spoken this way
and i get i kind of get what's happening
if i could learn how to speak like this
to strangers
maybe i can come home and finally talk
to my mom
and and and and have a boundary with my
parents my asian parents are [ __ ]
boundary-less you know
so that night i'm i'm i i'm like [ __ ] i
could get my toothbrush i got some stuff
from the room
and my friends like dude just we'll go
get it somewhere else you don't
like why you playing with fire again i'm
like because i like it when it hurts
and like dude the guy is totally made up
in his mind he's getting kicked out
because of you
like i just got to go to my room and i
just got to get my toothbrush in a
workbook and something and they're like
don't do it don't do it i'm like i have
to and it's like do you do you have to
like okay i don't maybe i don't have to
so i go up he's like i'll just wait here
in case something goes bad because that
guy can get violent
and i go in the room and he's sitting
there and he's like stewing he's like
stewing and he's like
watching like the final episode of
breaking bad and i'm like hey what's up
man
and i'm just like sort of go to my room
get my [ __ ]
and then i had to do it like i'm almost
out the door
and he's like i was
trying to guilt me i was almost out of
here dave you had to do it huh
i was like look man i don't know you
we've known each other for like a week
like i don't have anything against you
i'm just trying to get better i'm [ __ ]
i'm a sick person i can say that
i had a hard time saying that i had no
voice i'm a sick person and i'm willing
i'm [ __ ] helpless right now i'm
desperate i'm gonna do anything
right now to [ __ ] get better so if it
means i gotta tell on you
for googling me if i gotta tell on you
for watching breaking bad
because you like to do meth and suck
mexican guys dicks and
and vice versa and so i i get a little
cocky i get a little and i go
same thing like the hitchhiking like i
know i'm never going to see this guy
again
i go hey walter you've told me the whole
time we were here
you always got to end [ __ ] with i'm not
gay but i'm not gay
did you ever think that maybe instead of
like hiding who you are
finally divorcing your wife and like you
can go to like the gay parade and wear
crazy [ __ ] and just be out
you don't have to because his whole
thing is i only do it when i'm on meth
you don't have to use hide behind meth
anymore and he chuckled a little bit and
like in my head i'm like oh cool i'm
like maybe making maybe some of these
words are getting in
and he's like all right and so
i felt good like it felt like so i leave
and then i stayed at this place for six
more months
and during this time
i got to like learn and become like a
better version of myself
and learn new tools and like even
these people forgot how to have fun
they're like lawyers and doctors and
it's like entitlement out the roof
they're all the super best at their job
the best lawyer the best doctor the best
so they're used to like playing god and
saving people's lives and people just
catering to them so
they have they're all breaking bad
they're all walter whites they just
and and we're here as adults being
trained
and i'm like i'm gonna teach these
[ __ ] how to have fun so i'm like
making little scavenger hunts for them
and they're they like love me they're
like dave is the best he's teaching me
how to be a kid again
i'm doing scavenger hunts all across
walmart and sam's club
i'm teaching people how to like make
sculptures out of aluminum foil left
over from lunch
and people grown people are crying
they're like dave i haven't had this
much fun since i was like
my dad beat me into being the best
and so i leave this place and i'm like
i feel good and i get home and i get a
text
from a number i don't know this is like
seven six seven months later
and it's a picture of me sleeping in
that apartment
the guy [ __ ] took pictures of me
while sleeping
[ __ ] crazy
it is crazy that's
um the messed up dude took pictures of
you while you were sleeping yeah
and i remember thinking that night after
hearing the story of like how he
i was like maybe i should lock my door
and i never sure you should have
i should have but dave that's a crazy
story and i wish i could hear more but
it's 4 30.
is it really it's 4 30. we do this is a
four hour podcast right
ridiculous can i please please um invite
you to my next show
when is it so thank you by the way my
last show was two years ago
it was the cho show and you reposted the
billboard that i put up
and um painting for me is
i won't say it's boring but i just know
how to paint now in the same way like
you know how to do what you're good at
so i'm going to create a joe
joe a cho rogan experience for you oh
jesus
can we just not i really do i gotta go
it's 4 30. it's super late
okay can i can i just throw out the
hanza thing again
the just okay so if anyone's interested
in sponsoring a kid or learning more
about this culture
please go to hodza h-a-d-z-a dot org
and um if you're in la and you watch
your show
oh so yes i could talk forever
i have a tv show that i just sold
that i don't know the name of and i
don't know when it's going to be out
but just look out we'll check back in
with you later on all right
that's it thanks david show ladies and
gentlemen thank you
goodbye sorry that i just
[ __ ] [ __ ]